i'm playing mikko
thank you daniel
i'm [ __ ] nervous though man
are you grand master we're getting close
we're knocking on the door
only 2 000 more chess rating
thanks good
is 2000 a lot in chess it's about 20
years worth of
perfecting and practice
yeah 2000 is a lot
to go from 100 to three thousand that's
like your whole life dedicated to chess
yeah it is fun kraken thanks to the
resub scholar
i know who jay and silent bob are it's
clerks
yeah we watched it last night uzi it's
pretty wild
getting [ __ ] nervous man
thanks for the bits done
i said 2 000 more rating which would put
me at 3 100.
also 2000 is literally by definition not
trash level
2k is [ __ ] huge
what's the reason diddy
play mikko's bot to get ready
does she oh she does have a bot how do i
play well i'm going to keep this up
then actually i'll play miko's bot
where's your bot i don't think i've ever
played a bot
is it on computer
oh here we go
uh this is this is fine
no not the not the right one
that's dangerously close i wonder if
she's gonna push that up
you know what i'm just gonna develop
bishop here just out of curiosity
no she didn't
i want to take up the center right
why didn't she take back
i gotta be honest i don't exactly know
what's going on but i'll i'll take it
uh
this is so weird um
do i even want a castle or should i just
immediately start looking for a mate
here which i think i can get
let's just let's just go wild
um
damn i can't push that yet
damn
oh i don't know why i did that i tunnel
vision too hard
whoops
seems fine to me
what should i take with your bishop or
knight
or do i just want to deliver the check
first
so many [ __ ] options i'm taking with
the knight that
that's the one that makes the most sense
to
uh
it was made if i had taken there that
wasn't made
oh it would have been actually yeah
cause this was cut off
you're right
yeah damn you were right now i can't do
this because the bishop's there so if i
had just played that that would have
been made
you're absolutely right
put them back maybe she'll just repeat
moves
why can't i find this mate
this
where the [ __ ] is it
i feel like this should be such an easy
mate but i absolutely i mean it would
have been if i had just taken like i
said but
i feel like i'm still missing it
i mean i could just start taking pieces
but i'd much rather actually find this
all right let's just go wild i take here
you can't take one i mean you can't take
back but
i can't do that because of the bishop
still if i can get that bishop off
though what would be the next play
it's not gonna work
let's just chase queen
where was that [ __ ] mate from before
and we are back with day three for
pogchamps three presented by grip6 with
me is the one and only
the man him the legend i would say the
myth but you're the prophet that's what
you go by these days
i suppose i do well it's an honor to be
here danny i'm so excited for these
matchups we've got some absolutely mouth
or
mouthwatering matchups today i can't
wait uh to dig into these games
well uh right there with you and it's
it's uh
it's an honor as well your grandmaster
daniel neroditsky for those who don't
know of the legend but uh
we'll talk a little bit of course about
why you were nicknamed the prophet at
some point on the show today because
fate would have it that uh your your
student is playing so
let's let's jump in and remind everybody
of all 16 of the participants before we
break down
today's specific match-ups uh let me
just ask you donna we're now three days
in
and you've been watching as a fan just
like all of us it's
been an exciting moment or an exciting
player of all 16 of them in front of you
that maybe caught your eye
or surprised you at all with their with
their strength
i've been glued to the screen danny and
lots of these players are they're so
aggressive logic in particular
uh caught my eye of course there was a
scare that he survived with the mouse
lip
and of course sardoche the uh legend of
his work ethic has
gone the world round uh so we'll be
keeping a close eye on him and of course
mr beast just
because of how huge he is i'm just very
curious to see how he'll handle the
pressure of jess and of course
xbc he has improved tremendously so
i'll be excited to see how he uh his
performance in pogchamps three so
lots of players to uh look out for and
uh very interesting games today as well
and of course moist them not gonna lie
100 percent see how mr beast making his
debut today
um along with uh along with moyes his
return here to pogchamp so uh
all right yeah we'll get into all that
let's remind everybody the format you
see we still
we already got a lot of you hanging with
us whatever platform you're choosing to
watch from
thanks for being here uh the format is
of course
four groups of four the players will
play a double round robin which
in chess terms means you play with each
color white and black
you get three points for an outright
match win two if it takes tie breaks to
win
and then one point goes to the person
who lost in tie breaks armageddon if it
goes to that
then of course the top two players from
each group advance to either the
championship or
top two advance to the championship
bracket the bottom two advance to the
consolation bracket
and the bracket stage is single
elimination the prices are bigger than
ever donya i know you got that memo but
it's 100k now
up from 50k here in the third edition
and even more importantly we have a
community element
we've been raising money throughout and
i'm sure we're going to hit our goal
i believe in it let's go ahead and bring
up the community
graphic to remind everybody of where we
stand currently
and we will uh remind you of how you how
you can get involved in help
we're also going to remind you where you
can go to see the different charities
that the players have chosen a lot of
you've been asking of that
and we'll let you know all the different
charities uh that you could donate for
if your favorite player ends up winning
uh so
gonna be awesome donya the uh the
charity element i'm super excited to see
where we get and this is where we
currently stand
in terms of the groups and what we've
seen so far
indeed danny so much at stake here and
love to see the community outreach
as we have a bird's eye view of some of
the match-ups here
as we discussed so many interesting
players uh these groups will be
hotly contested and uh that's going to
continue with
uh today's matchup stand yeah and let's
uh let's look at that so
as you said we've got code miko uh the v
tuber
rockin the first match of the day versus
moist critical
uh charlie is is uh one of the fan
favorites
for crazy moments in the first pog
champs and he's back here
in pog3 and it's going to be awesome to
see i know i you mentioned xqc of course
who has improved a ton we know that
charlie has also improved a ton
budwig was streaming a bunch of chess
last night that matchup versus him and
mr beast is
is is frankly i think what most people
are super pumped seated
that doesn't take anything away from
anybody but it's partly because of their
their banter we'll get into that in a
minute
in fact right there in fact daniel did
you see this go down on twitter just
moments ago between mr beast and ludwig
i did not danny am i reading this right
i'll give you 10
000 if you do so what is hope you don't
mind me taking your king today these are
some fighting words danny they're
getting into it before the first move is
made that's what i love to see
i love it they've been getting into it
all all i guess
lead up to the event they've had some
they've had some pretty funny moments
back and forth and uh
i i think ludd is serious we know that
he throws money down sometimes
although we also know that he says
things that are completely ridiculous
like the fact that he goes to chess.com
to beat the danny bot and you are
welcome blood to upload that on twitter
the moment you uh
show that you you beat the dannybot
anytime buddy all right but moving on
let's remind everybody of another huge
event coming up with our
partners at twitch on march 2nd it's our
next
twitch rivals and chess.com partnered
event this time it's going to be hand in
brain
it's going to be awesome they've just
announced that the next twitch rivals
will be featuring
some of your favorite creators ludwig
voyboy the boteslive hicaro they're
playing hand in brain
and i actually have a real-time update
from one of the leads at twitch
right now uh then it's actually thirty
five thousand dollars in prices not
twenty five thousand
and uh it will take place on march
second i can't wait
um and uh i think i think you might be
there as well donna
were you are you involved in that
uh i think so i mean i'll definitely uh
make time and i love hand and brain it's
such a good spin on the game and it
always results in really really fun
chess so i'm
really looking forward to that danny
that'll be march 2nd
1pm pacific start time i can't wait for
that either
yeah it's going to be a big hand in
brain is so much so much fun you pair
different levels of chess and
and then let the cards fall where they
may before we jump back into today's
specific matchups another shout out to
gaia ki yerba mate of course we want to
take a moment to thank our sponsors for
all of our sponsors for pogchamps 3
presented by grip 6
but right now talking about gaia key as
they celebrate 25 years of your favorite
regenerative
yerba mate they're sharing cases to
celebrate spam the gaia key emote
in chat for your chance to win and we
will be back after
after a very quick break to start the
first matches of the day
four pillars of regeneration to heal all
nations
we work with and not against because we
are a part of this
we've never been apart from this our
hands feel through the soils past
our feet touch on the blades of grass
raid all these voices into a beautiful
tapestry find those similarities we all
share in these breaths that we breathe
this home of ours sustains us but needs
us
so together we'll move through this long
night and inspire us all to come to life
i will fill out the game with time to
think
but honestly honestly honestly guys
chess is just a game anyway
it doesn't doesn't mean anything
it doesn't mean anything okay chess is
just a game
um it's not like everyone's gonna
remember this game
[Music]
i mean probably people probably won't to
be honest
people probably really won't
we will all right my my chat might
but but but but you know but you know
the rest of the world
won't so you know it'll be like it will
be like it never happened
okay if nobody remembers it
does it mean it actually happened
oh
oh if no one remembers it
doesn't actually mean it existed
i say no
all right guys i'm gonna get ready
for ultimate humiliation although i am
into it
i am into it so uh maybe maybe it's
it'll be a fun thing
um all right let's see
the score
okay
okay log into okay got it whoa
one being my gifting 10 tier one cells
lucky
subs for play for we currently
definitely need
we definitely need it
i am at chess.com live mr chess
thank you thank you slight delay three
more minutes
ah three more minutes
ah
charlie will destroy you i'm into it
i'm into it destroy me charlie
make me feel you wrecking
my pieces
this is the most action i've gotten in
the last eight months
last three weeks
do it wreck me
i can't wait what do you mean out of
context
what why are you guys wearing champagne
you're oh wait wait what is your
opponent what is my ass when you tell me
my ass what was it what
my odds are 1 to 23. you guys if you bet
on me and i win you'll become a
millionaire
do you know that if you just bet
a hundred dollars on me you will get
23 100 times 23.
100 times like 20 23 23.
2 300.
[Music]
jesus
[Applause]
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about
magic time
we're in the game
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
watch that video all day i know what's
going on your head
bob your head it's all right pretty good
hype video
i was that was awesome i was vibing to
that but i'm going to be biting into the
games too
well the games are about to start any
second the
the team is ready the players are ready
we saw uh code miko talking about
how if someone had just put 100 bucks on
her maybe they'd become a millionaire
when she when she wins the whole thing
so she was fun to talk trash apparently
she's an underdog i didn't even know
that
but uh this is going to be this is going
to be awesome here
and the game should be beginning shortly
so you know
you know charlie better than anyone here
at thechest.com streaming community
how how uh how pumped is he to be back
here
uh in pogchamps and and uh what what
chances you give him to maybe be one of
the better players
he's definitely pumped that i know he's
also definitely nervous and
i always point this out these uh stars
these streamers
they are used to broadcasting to
millions and millions of people danny
but there's something
about sitting behind a chessboard be it
a virtual chess board or a real chess
board that brings out all the anxiety
and i actually really like that so
charlie he's experienced
he knows what this is like at the same
time uh
we're gonna watch his time consumption
and uh i don't know
too much about code muco but i think
she's put in the work
well right now she started out pretty
pretty well she played some natural
developing moves right i mean this is
um not the most traditional approach
against a sicilian and charlie handles
it like a pro with e6 and d5 but but
there's some risk in an opening like
this if if miko can
can play aggressively in the center
early on maybe she'll maybe she'll be
okay here
yeah for sure she needs to strike in the
center d4
uh get her pieces out quickly rookie
wants she goes d3 she's doing everything
right preparing the development of her
dark square bishop and charlie
quickly focusing on getting that king to
safety
uh by castling yeah bishop v7
supernatural move but this is
this is a great start i mean even though
we were saying d4 i actually kind of
liked that she played d3 because it
protects against c4 maybe maybe she
she would have got her bishop trap so
this is some really awesome principal
chess she's bringing out her pieces and
all right now i'm nervous i'm excited
i'm excited too this is great and
they're both getting their pieces out
doing everything right
mikko brings her last piece out charlie
still has that dark light squared bishop
to bring out
uh which he can put on a bunch of
different squares and um
they are following the fundamentals to
the letter name
yeah and you know something about the
way she's playing two just the tempo of
it right even if this is
the most traditional approach against
charlie sicilian she's playing all these
developing moves with confidence if you
look at the fact that she has nine and a
half minutes
so i'm gonna do the early kind of
hecarim call to action and just say
i kind of think she's underrated at 333
he tends to kind of look at the ratings
and see how they play and i i would say
now
that she's probably underrated at 300.
she absolutely is and i completely agree
with you
just by these first moves uh she's
showing complete command of the
fundamentals and uh
you don't do that you know if you're if
you've had one chest listen so she's
definitely been putting in the work now
charlie
um i'm gonna be straight up with you
danny he he has a big weakness in terms
of his time consumption
when he's playing casually uh he he
plays confidently but when he's on the
big stage
sometimes he freezes so we'll see
whether he can uh he can control that
here in this game we're going to throw
to him right now for the first time
today and see what charlie's thinking
about
we're not thinking
i'm not gonna do anything too crazy here
he's illuminating even his thoughts here
tanya
so deep you can't express them
wow he's not usually this silent you're
telling me
uh like you said you you know him well
and he's nervous um he's obviously gonna
like to trap
this bishop see what he's considering by
by what he's doing with the pieces and
where he's moving his mouse um but uh
but i think she's going to want to take
to double my pawns
yeah he's that's some pretty high level
thinking he sees that
miko probably wants to take that knight
[Music]
i don't remember if we care about double
pawns in this line or not
that's also high level thinking right
there because it is
recognizing it and then using i'm taking
too long already
right i'm just going to say we don't
care about double pawns and go for it
what's going on
did that just happen
let's let's come back here to the main
board and i you played bishop f4
in point one i'm pretty sure she had
accidentally clicked it for a pre-move
or she or she was pre-moving which would
be you know kind of a surprise kind of
uh
you know high-level play there for her
to pre-move and and maybe not a very
smart one with
with charlie playing b5 but let's throw
to code mikko now for the first time and
see
what she's thinking about it's okay it's
fine
oh my god here he comes here comes the
pummeling guys
um
the pummeling i have not been looking
forward to
but kinda yes
oh jesus that's scary
all right well i guess we'll have oh
jesus that's not good um
um you know what you know what guys
you know what i'm just spence
i'm just gonna go
here
not a great move
okay more than six news okay
probably does it
all right
that's what she's missed
[Laughter]
[Music]
shut up okay
she's playing so fast that's that's the
thing that i would advise her yep
oh
shut up shut up everyone oh wait what
oh i didn't even
oh i didn't even say hey
you know what guys you know what we
we did it was more than six moves
that's that's for sure um
she did good that by her saying that
makes me feel like she just kind of knew
she was the underdog but the truth is
her position she was doing well if maybe
she just slowed down a little bit right
i think it started here with her
pre-moving bishop f4
and then obviously the wheels kind of
come off pretty quickly from there so
i think that sometimes the players come
in done and they're just a little maybe
a little psyched out and that that
definitely feels like one of those which
is unfortunate because i think
i think she showed some things that were
better than where this game ended so
quickly
absolutely her development was on point
she showed an ability to see where the
pieces belong
and she responded to threats when
charlie attacked one of her pieces she
moved it back
but i completely agree with you i think
the issue was that pre-move
and as you said the wheels came up when
you blunder a piece it can be so
disheartening
and even subconsciously you can sort of
lose lose your ability to
approach the position objectively but
still definitely impressive stuff in the
opening
yeah i agree and um obviously we're
always
surprised and not surprised with dog
champs games and things that happen
sometimes but
i think that where this game started
dylan i'm surprised it ended the way it
did that's what i'm that's what i'm
gonna say do you
do you agree with that completely agree
and i think
uh on move 11 she probably should have
followed through
with uh capturing charlie's knight just
so that her bishop doesn't get trapped
and uh
right i think you know sometimes these
players just a little bit
of confidence is lacking and following
through on their ideas but by and large
uh you know she's gonna hold her head up
high yeah no
i agree and you're right so right here
she played bishop a4 as charlie was
saying we were listening in
maybe she wants to take my knight and
double the pawns but and then she kind
of
left that plan behind and we see the
eval bar reveal exactly how the computer
feels about that
d5 and uh you know at this point while
bishop four was a premium
as you're saying the bishop is already
trapped and so the game was
in theory you know grand master level
chess black is already winning
and but but i think that it's less about
that i think it was more indicative like
right here i think sometimes
one of the things that we learn as you
get better at chess like when a player
attacks you don't always have to meet
fire with fire
right so so a retreating move is
sometimes in order
but but it feels like no no that then
that means i'm losing right but then by
definition you play the really
aggressive move and lose
and and that's kind of kind of what
happened here because the wheels came
off super quickly and
got up to charlie though i mean i guess
obviously he's doing what he came to do
getting some dubs and uh pogchamps three
presented by grip6 and uh
and here we go man what do you think
your students feel right now what would
you be advising him to stay focused
yeah definitely he's got to stay focused
keep the foot on the gas pedal it's a
two game match
and uh it can be devastating to lose the
second game after winning the first
uh so you know he's got to reward him
reorient himself and
there were points in this first game
where i think he took a little bit too
much time so he can quickly go
over that and sort of figure out where
he could have played a little bit faster
but right
he's got to refocus and uh you know
still you've got to take your time it's
very important not to make any sloppy
pre-moves
but you sound like a coach she's almost
just hoping he's watching you right now
but okay so
speaking of the fact that there is a
next game there's actually a lot of
games still coming up here
in pogchamps so uh if you haven't
already grab your grab your phone right
now everyone's got some sort of google
calendar sync these days and type it in
and you know you cancel the dentist
appointment and you and you add
oh yeah i gotta be here i gotta be here
uh on wednesday the 17th for
xqc taking on poking me so uh there's
the schedule at least for the
dentist sorry say that say it again
what's that what's a dentist yeah
appointment what is it
yeah who needs who needs teeth right
oral hygiene a duck
right okay here we go that was weird it
was february 18th
we've got uh only two matchups but they
are big ones we've got michelle care
versus logic then we've got rain
versus tubbo um and the games the games
continue right there before you
the bracket stage uh or sorry the group
stage comes to an end on the 21st
and we will have our first rest day a
break day for us to kind of work with
all the players and the streamers and
their busy schedules and and make sure
that things are lined up
for the bracket stage to begin on
february 23rd
and on that note this will be how it
looks right you have the players put
into seedings accordingly based on how
they perform here in the groups
and we play until we have a pog champs
winner pog champs three presented by
grip six
now the winner's gonna get a belt can i
like show the belt right now
that against our sponsor we got to see
it
you i mean am i allowed to i'm asking
for i do things all the time to get us
in trouble and then get dms and say no
dan
dan you weren't supposed to do that
there it is baby
oh man yeah it's sweet that is awesome
it's good it's it's not just a trunk
it's titanium enough
to hold up a fat guy's pants and then
you just
right there so whoever gets this i think
that i think that they will be streaming
with it behind them for the rest of
their streaming career
the podcamp's belt is pretty awesome
it is you can't just leave that anywhere
it has to occupy the central place
uh in this game that's awesome danny i
like it it's not just a trophy it's
creative it's not
just a trophy right it's a belt why
don't more chess turners have belt right
i mean ufc's been doing it you know
heavyweight wrestling i miss hulk hogan
i miss you hulk hogan okay moving on to
the bots
let's remind you you can play bots uh
whether you're into playing v tubers
or um people who claim to be bots that
they could never be
like ludwig go beat ludwig's bot in fact
if anyone beats ludwig's bot
and tweets it at me with like a funny
phrase i'm gonna choose one today and
just give away a one-year diamond
membership because it makes ludwig's day
bad and makes me happy it's a win-win
makes the moment i heard makes you happy
i was gonna do it but you know danny you
disawaited me from it why'd you have to
say that
jokes aside jokes aside we're gonna take
our first break of the day when we come
back it's game two
code miko versus moist critical don't go
anywhere pog champs three presented by
grip six when we return
burger tier list win i'm trying not to
do too many food tier lists i'm doing a
lot of food
how many games have you won in chess in
total i don't know man i've played
so so so many games of chess i have no
[ __ ] idea
i have no goddamn clue
still miko we play we play more
makes the prime kevin in the prime
x
we're doing a baby food tier list i
think that's the next one but i'm trying
not to do too many food ones
i really wanted to do the edible [ __ ]
tier list but
the only one that was up to up for it
was pay money wobby
so i mean i can't just like tier list
one [ __ ]
i need more
resub just joe in the prime ayman
you're live on chess like right now
like they heard my okay if we're live on
chess right now
don't steal my edible [ __ ] to your
list please i'm still trying to get more
people for it i saw ludwig say he'll do
it
i just need like six or seven people of
my friends
not random people because i already know
they're just gonna send me like dirty
[ __ ] mold
makes the two gift subs sensei
in the prime juice box and the resub
salad
hey to tie it back into chess yeah i
could try a bunch of grand masters
chocolate buttholes it's a it's a
company that does them so you mold you
mold your [ __ ] with some alginate
you send it in they turn it into
chocolate and i can just try different
buttholes and see which grandmasters
taste the best
it could be a whole chess.com event
you've seen the grand masters but how do
they taste
thanks theresa meyers in the gift sub
pog in the prime as raj
think positive you got this ah yes
positive thinking can achieve the
impossibles
be positive
are we positive thinkers
are we positive dreamers do we dream
or do we meme
we do both when we dream a meme at the
same time there's nothing we cannot do
we can achieve
everything
we are clock positive
together
damn when is when is it gonna start
ah we still have a few minutes
let's go baby let's go
six move uh more than six move
let's go
let's do it let's do it let's do it
let's do it hey
and we are back pogchamps 3 presented by
grip 6.
you heard it you heard it from code miko
if you dream and meme
anything is possible dreaming and
memeing together is a win
absolutely it's a two-game match she's
pumping herself up
we saw some signs of mastery in game one
so uh this match is far from over
all right well the games are going to
begin any second
we'll see what uh what code miko does
with the black pieces
obviously charlie will have white i like
that dream and meme
i'm gonna i'm gonna steal that one for
later um but
uh anyway thanks for being with us no
matter where you're tuning in from
here we go it's gonna be an awesome day
we got mystery ludwig up ahead we got
crazy stuff charlie plays e4 here we go
and an e5 from code miko and the vienna
gambit is what charlie has been playing
over the last couple of weeks that's
where white goes f4 pretty quickly but
here
he develops his bishop yeah this is a
really aggressive line right obviously
when you play f4 at some point the
f-file will lead
the rook and bishop having a date right
there on f7 or at least they hope to
and the pressure becomes very very very
very strong very quickly depending on
whether black knows what to do
so uh miko already given it a think
right here
right it's not the most common opening
which is part of the reason that
uh it's very effective because if you
can get your opponent out of their
comfort zone pretty early and you know
the ideas you get a pretty big edge on
the clock and
often that translates into an advantage
over the board right
well now already white has the option to
play f4
and you can also play d3 if you still
want to sort of slow jam the idea
um of course you always have the option
of going back into a more traditional
kind of whatever that would be
two nights four nights but no as we
already we already know because uh
because we have the profit here f4
is charlie's weapon what do you think is
going to happen at some point in the
event when he plays against someone
who's prepared for his vienna
how's that gonna go well he's gonna have
to tighten up the screws
the thing with these openings right if
they work out for you you can score some
quick victories
if you mess up the move order you mess
up one move it's a double-sided sword
and you can get in trouble pretty darn
fast but uh so far charlie's showing
nice command of the principles getting
rid of the pin immediately
yeah and the risk as you said because if
it goes wrong what you've done
is open up a lot of dark squares but
okay here we see
an example of how it goes right a lot a
lot of times people don't
really realize how aggressive this line
can be and just like that your bishop is
trapped
yeah komiko bishop trapped on one side
of the board and now it's trapped on the
other side of the board in the other
game
and she does the right thing giving it
up for a pawn if you're losing a piece
you want to give it up for as much as
possible
yeah she takes it that's a good move and
i and i again i think the only thing i
would say
is obviously it's hard you know when you
when you feel like you're playing a
stronger player
but i think that she may be like we said
in game one thinks she's a little worse
than she is
and and is playing kind of too fast if
she if she slows down a little bit
you know um because the openings she's
had are very principled right she's
gotten pieces out she understands all of
those all of those development
kind of ideas and we'll see if she gets
castle here
it's the king out of the center yeah
she's she's developing all her pieces
and you can't say it enough it's not
that easy to get
into a situation where you have
commanded the principles and that's
exactly what she has
uh maybe again maybe taking a little bit
more time would have been good
but these unconventional positions they
can be hard to get your footing in but
other than that
you know you could confuse or play for
that of magnus or maybe gary caspara
yeah i mean what would gary kasparov
think about this position
well if only we had him on the show but
danny tim
this reminds me of the match against uh
another court company
and uh in that match you know it was uh
back and forth you know looking for the
game but him
go to mikko now she she knows um
how to develop her pieces you know but
like a good russian school boy
do you think do you think good russian
school boys gary was a busy man
would good russian school boys
appreciate the v tuber experience you
think
gary
you know where i come from you know it's
um the v2 marine is i'm old school you
know i like
uh flip phones you know notebooks you
know button
i can definitely appreciate you know the
sort of the rise you know the ai and you
know
i've spoken about it you know in
colleges in it before but um
overall you know i'm quite approving of
you know the strength
okay there you go thank you gary um
we'll uh maybe check in with you a
little bit later all right look at this
move knight h5 from her
when mikko puts that on h5 it opens up
the check and we see charlie make his
first
kind of odd move of the day let's listen
into code miko and see if she sees the
check and what she can do here drawing
is important
but that's gonna get that guy
so then you
uh no i wanna i wanna get rid of some of
my
some of my pieces are so stuck uh
that night on age five
exactly wanted to do anything
oh [ __ ] i know what he's trying to do
he's trying to
okay okay okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait i get what he's trying to do
all right
wait why can't i do this um
i'm confused
um don't worry
don't don't panic don't panic everybody
don't panic okay
don't panic just don't panic
nobody panic it's okay nobody panic
i'm not either uh
nobody we're not panicking i don't
understand why i can't move this
but um nobody panics stop penegate
okay stop yelling danny why are you
panicking danny
why are you panicking
okay queen d7 and backing up a couple
moves it actually is unfortunate that
she just didn't realize
knight h2 was played quickly by charlie
but probably a little too quickly
because he
you know if she had played the move
bishop h4
check right
right and that would have forced the
king to move and when the king has to
move this early danny
it can land in some danger yeah there's
uh there's knight g3 coming there's all
kinds of stuff happening so
um okay she played 95 as we saw
instead and uh lost the knight and now
we'll see if charlie
can see how dangerous the g file is the
uh computer is actually announcing mate
and six but let's see what charlie sees
yeah and what you can see here white is
up two pieces and there's also this g
file white's got a rook positioned and
facing right at black's king
and that pawn that is covering the king
is very flimsy you can attack that pawn
with a variety of pieces you can bring
your bishop out all the way to h6
and the pawn you could just choose
bishop because it is
yeah the he's not he's not talking i
don't know how best to approach this
mate
this is something i also need to work on
i see a lot of different mating options
here
i see a [ __ ] ton of mating options i
just don't know
like the best and fastest way of doing
it
i mean like i could literally drop queen
back i could push queen up
because this is pinned she cannot take
i'm just gonna push it up that's the
best move
that's the fastest mate got it easy
he's hesitating though
and he's d he's done it
queen is untouchable because of the
thing to me that looks okay if she comes
here i can just take the bishop
if she pushes this up i do the original
plan
seeing things very clearly
yeah that's impressive that's an
impression using the pen
he's nervous he's worried there's a
defensive resource somewhere
but there isn't any
do i want to just take that with any of
the three pieces actually
doing her best block the g file but
unfortunately it's just
hold the pin oh yep now it's and now
it's made on g7
and there it is
wow that was a commanding attack there
by charlie i had a lot of different
options there
i had a [ __ ] ton of options
i just didn't know how to best approach
it in the fastest way
i feel like i had a faster option
i just don't know what it was
he actually actually didn't he actually
didn't have a faster option so
um
real talk he was he was awesome um i
mean we can we can
go through it real quick the computer
was first
pointing i mean really knight h2 was um
was less than ideal of a move right if
if
uh black is still down a piece but if
miko had seen bishop h4 check
the game could have been very different
right um one thing you one thing you
noted
is that um again players as they as they
gain experience sometimes
are just looking after you do the basics
of development like what's a one move
thread i could play so
she she was feeling cramped and was kind
of looking for her next threat
but they but they don't always see the
threat for their opponent coming right
and that's that's where this backfired
and right here after queen d7 it's
already a forced mate
was there anything fancier he could have
done besides queen h6 i don't think so
i don't think so either you could have
sacrificed the rook on g7 but that was
counterproductive because you want to
keep the rook
it's the main attacker you could have
also brought the bishop to h6 but
queen h6 was both the most elegant move
and the fastest checkmate and that's an
area where charlie has improved
tremendously danny that area he was
unsure but his intuition
indicated the best and fastest way to
make
yep well rook takes g5
and uh this is this is this was already
already over
and so so ali ali i guess
uh ouch town
yeah i mean as i said mikko's going to
hold her head up high she's
doing a lot of things right and she's
going to keep improving yeah and i think
that
again sometimes in the in the early the
early rounds right you're you're kind of
everyone is sort of figuring out the
strength of the players and i think that
uh
mikko if and when she hooks up with her
coaches will be told like hey you
weren't doing bad you got all your
pieces developed
right just focus on a little more
emphasis on your opponent's threats and
slow down just a little bit right
i think that that would probably be the
advice we would want to give her
and i'm being given uh and told the cue
that it's time for us to take a break
before we
are joined by our players for an
interview so don't go anywhere
interviews with moist critical and code
miko when pogchamps 3 presented by grip
6
returns
three would mean a lot if you checked it
out
i'll check it out bud you get 3 000 if
you get
dead last thank you polite for the host
brother
3k if you get dead last if you lose
every single game
for about maybe
three hours of your time two hours of
your time thousand dollars an hour
that's not bad
that's not bad 1k an hour
that pays for like one of code miko's
cogs
all right what do we got
oh [ __ ] it's on me hey uh
what's up uh um i don't know you guys
don't have a name
what's up chess.com uh are you guys
wondering why
watch uh why would one player wanna play
game when they
get [ __ ] on we make three thousand
dollars if we lose every game
it's one thousand dollars an hour to be
a loser
it's the greatest deal of all time i
don't think
that you get a lot of money when you
lose most of the time
i don't know somebody asked the new york
jets i'm not aware
perhaps the knicks might have more
information on this fact
all i'm saying is that's a pretty sweet
deal
anyway if you guys don't know um
chess.com that is uh
check this out mr beast tweeted at me
this afternoon and he said
hope you don't mind me taking your king
today
and then in a spout of courage in
stupidity i tweeted i'll give you ten
thousand if you do
thinking that he would be like yeah you
know cause it's mr beast you'd be like
yeah let's put 10k on it thinking
i could get like a free 10k
and then he just followed up and said um
i'll take it in bitcoin um
so he didn't really
hold up his end of the bargain there i
thought that was gonna be
i thought it was gonna be like you know
yeah let's do it 10k grudge match
i don't even know what it means he said
takes your king does that mean beats me
in the whole set or if he wins one game
do i
do i give 10k if he wins two games do i
lose 20k
we don't know the specifics stressed out
man i'm stressed out
we'll be fine we'll be fine
dream is streaming react and get free
clout
genius
what the [ __ ] and then on top of that
dude [ __ ] twitch on god i hate this
[ __ ] website
i started streaming like three years ago
and i wanted to be the biggest streamer
and back in the day it was like soda pop
and he had like 25k
he hit like 70k once with an unboxing he
was like the biggest stream ever
now [ __ ] tommy and it's dumbass gets
like 100k
natty doing whatever the [ __ ] i'm out
here
starving trying to get 20k viewers doing
whatever i can putting up 10k for
[ __ ]
diddly squat 53k on shroud
for crumbs crumbs what
happened to twitch bro it used to be so
easy
how am i supposed to get the biggest on
twitch it's impossible
i don't know i don't know i hate it i
hate it
i hate it here what is the point
i'm your crumb thanks thanks for the
crumb of couch chat
i appreciate it but god damn
has my dream died with dream smp
being the actual murder ironic dream
killed my dream
anyway um if you guys could all
consider starting i think the best way
to grow is for everybody to live tweet
my stream so if you guys could hop on
twitter
um oh my god can't believe ludwig
uh said that and then
you have to like basically click bait
people who follow you to be like what
they say
okay you guys are just saying no all
right i'm just gonna run three minutes
of ads
well they did a countdown on chess.com i
was hoping it would leave
and we are now joined by mikko and
charlie after this first match on day
three
of pogchamps uh great games great games
guys uh
mikko we i wanted to look at the chess
because we were listening in on you
during during some of the games and
there were some moments where it felt
like maybe you thought your position was
worse than it was and maybe we could
look at some of this and and go over
some tips for the future if that's okay
yes please okay cool
so in this position here you actually
had a great opening to start you
developed all your pieces and got
castled and
even charlie was recognizing when you
played bishop a4 that
maybe you had a plan to double his pawns
and then right here
it it felt like you started playing
really fast on the clock your next
couple moves were with the bishop on
this side of the board
and that's where obviously we can see
how the computer feels about it that's
where it kind of started to go
haywire and and you got your bishop trap
so take us through what your thought
process was
once you got your pieces developed and
what are you thinking about
for future games um well
i i accidentally misclicked
and i did a pre-move and i didn't know
that was a thing
uh i'm just knuckles that's what i
hypothesized as well
there's no way that's code miko she's
too smart for that
yeah well not i'm not exactly i mean
but yeah i misclicked and then i also
accidentally hit the back button so i
almost left the game too
oh got it yeah that's what we were
thinking as well
okay so um yeah that's awesome
news because that's what we were we
wanted we wanted to go over it and give
advice because your position was great
um did you think about when you played
bishop a4 were you thinking about taking
the night here
yep of course i was
uh-huh yeah that would have been a good
idea to double charlie's funds and
then your bishop wouldn't have landed in
as much trouble yeah perhaps you could
have attacked that pawn by
shifting your knight over to the center
right yeah
the uh the this this game this game
ended up
um you know like i said it started out
really well and even this one here
there was a position right here charlie
i don't know if you know when you played
knight h2 which obviously had this
threat
if miko had played bishop h4 check this
could have got a little spicy charlie
did you did you see this idea coming
uh that's definitely not where i wanted
to put the knight i just didn't know the
right square for it and i was trying not
to overthink it yeah i definitely didn't
see that though wait i have a free night
grab
not so much that but more that you could
have uh weakened white's king because
when you give a check this early forces
the king out into the open
yeah and then you can follow up by
shifting your knight into g3 with
another check
and it's not terrible for white but it
creates uh
some you know some unbalanced uh
situation here oh my god i'm learning so
much
well and it felt like maybe maybe the
takeaway too is is
obviously you did a great job in both
openings getting all the pieces out
getting the king safe
and then it felt like maybe you were you
were looking for a plan and one of the
best ways to look for a plan is trying
to improve the
the less active pieces the the worst
pieces so like maybe here looking for an
opportunity to improve the queen and
bishop
staying on this side of the board where
you had played the last move sometimes
the easiest way to have a good plan
is to stack moves on the same side of
the board like rather than sort of
what happened where you where you played
moves on different sides of the board
back to back
it kind of leads to a disjointed plan
whereas if you if you try to build up
pieces on the same side of the board
your army's working together
and so rather than just the specific
bishop h4 tip
maybe that's a tip for future games
right look to move all your pieces on
one side of the board a little more
coordinated
oh that's awesome i didn't know that
i'm super apologetic it wasn't what we
played but we just wanted to go over the
games because you guys
you guys uh gave us a treat and charlie
obviously you played super well so
obviously the serious question has to
come just how long is your hair now
oh i i haven't measured it but it's got
to be pushing like uh
one or two feet right like it's probably
a good percentage of my overall height
at this point since i have the height of
like a child like we've got to be
getting pretty close to that threshold
well as your rating grows so does your
hair
ain't that the truth yeah i get more
powerful yeah so
charlie just one quick question for you
do you feel
uh similar to how you did in pogchamps
one do you feel like that experience
is making you less nervous or is it uh
the sort of same kind of sensation
oh absolutely not i think it's a lot
more nerves this time because
i won the the losers bracket the
consolation participation trophy bracket
and now i'm like almost expected to win
some games and i think that sucks that
[ __ ] is tough
man having to play with like an
expectation to do well
yeah definitely can relate i've been
playing with low expectations on me for
years
so you can come back my way whenever
you're ready low expectations
um mikko what about you start taking the
games
nico this is your first blog champs
event get out from me
how are you feeling yes
oh i was really really excited i'm super
nervous to go against
like literally chest jesus himself um
but i was just really happy that i did
more than six moves yeah no i think
that's great
that was one of the finest performances
i've seen in pogchamps typically i'm
slapping cheeks around six moves
you went all the way to like 12 in some
cases
yay that's why i was saying go more if
we just do more than six moves we're
winning for me today
amen exactly
well we'll be looking for you to improve
um that was very well played both of you
you guys were nice thanks for showing
the tips i think
uh i'll use that for my next tournament
yeah well obviously you've got board
members and what are your thoughts over
the next couple weeks
you're gonna have you're gonna have two
more matches in the group and then
either the championship or consolation
bracket are you are you looking to get
some some coaching and crush
some peeps from here or you just you're
just kind of here for the experience
my group d is very very very
fun um ludwig is gonna be fun to play
against
i played against his bot and he
completely crushed me
um and then i'm really looking forward
to mr beast because i've heard from my
chat that mr beast is like my level so
that's going to be
fun um i'm going to get some more
coaching
and um and just have more fun i think
charlie have you beaten it's the wrong
mentality miko there's no fun here
no no no no brutalize people miko yeah
i will work day and night to brutalize
ludwig next week
or that should be easy his bot is so
much better than him anyway like when
you play real ludwig it's going to be
night and day yeah really
oh yeah he cannot play even like his bot
wait seriously
no okay i honestly think he just uses
the chat when he plays games and just
takes their moves i've never seen him
have an original thought
wow ah them fighting words
thanks moist for giving me courage i'll
tell my child to put all
in on me next time oh absolutely that's
a safe bet
uh you guys have been great uh charlie
again congrats and starting your your
pogchamps return
got pressure on yourself this time but
you're also you you've gotten so much
better man over the last few months
it's been awesome to watch your crush in
it and mikko
these were good games good start to the
event and best of luck in in the next
round
thank you so much guys thanks for having
me thank you thank you
great games all right
well that was that was fun and you know
i definitely agree
with charlie about ludwig's chess
experience and strength
for her oh absolutely yeah i mean i
think i've lost the live wig spot before
and i actually haven't but
i'm pretty sure i will but charlie and
ludwig will play
i wonder i would pay to just see charlie
bot
play against ludwigbot on chess.com with
the two of them comment commenting over
it
and just uh just commentating over their
bot battling against each other could be
great
uh remind chad if you upload the first
one to upload a video of you beating
lovely bot today gonna get a diamond
membership for me on twitter
while you're while you're waiting for
the next match go ahead and throw me
throw me a video if you beat lovebookbot
on twitter so
anyway this is this is already a lot of
fun we've got lud coming up versus mr
beast if you missed it
uh more is on the line in this matchup
between love wig and mr beast
then then even the the pog champs money
so don't go anywhere
we'll remind you of what what banter's
been going on on social media
when we come right back
boyfriend applications for v2 or mika
and it's going to turn into a game show
it's gonna be it's gonna first start
with me and reviewing your boyfriend
applications for vtuber
then we're gonna move on to a job a
hiring
it's gonna be like the office where i
will interview
these boyfriends
like they do in the office and then it's
gonna
turn into a full-on game show full-on
competitive game show
so guys wait i'm on chess tv wait what
what do you mean what do you mean i'm
still in just tv i shouldn't be i
shouldn't be on chess tv i should be
stop trolling me
anyways i love you guys
let's go
rest up i'm gonna go rest up and
the 27th is my birthday everybody
we're having an incredible stream
we're not trolling off freaking hell i
mean
guys hello
chess tv um i did not know i was on
chess tv
i'm sorry for um if i said anything that
was not just
i love you all thanks so much for having
me on chess tv
um yeah i love
i love everybody there yeah i understand
i'm on chess tv i understand
okay you you've told me that already i i
get it now
i'm good i'm good anyway i love you guys
um 27th is my birthday we have we are
we're gonna we're having a technician
stream but we're having a technician
stream like no other
has seen on stream before we're gonna
have the most
we're gonna do something that no twist
stream has ever done before
on twitch so
come for my birthday stream that is
on the 27th i'm going to set up a p.o
box
and one of the things that we're gonna
do is open up presents that you guys
have sent me
on the po box and um
yeah guys if you have not already uh
join my patreon so and if you have
joined my patreon make sure you write
your username
on my patreon on the post you will see
it because we
will start shouting out patreon names
um what else do i have anything else
um
dr k is tomorrow tomorrow is technician
stream
and we are going to be on dr k tomorrow
i will be there will be tears
um and we're going to be talking about i
think i'm going to change the topic to
my
workaholic uh situation
and how i feel guilty about
spending time with my friends or things
like that
um there's gonna be tears
um and then after that we're gonna go on
cash up trivia
then after that oh
i have to plan out oh okay this saturday
and sunday is gonna be interesting i
have to lock down
times and dates but um this this weekend
might get really interesting
okay everybody i love you guys um
i will uh talk to you guys later
and um i'll i'll see you guys on my
discord
i love you all thank you so much for
joining this chess stream today with me
let's go lightweight i'll promise i'll
try to spend some time practicing more
chess
i love you guys bye
join my youtube subscribe to your
youtube channel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and before our next match takes off we
are now joined by
mr beast himself one of the biggest
youtubers in the world
and jimmy i gotta ask before the match
starts what charity will you donate
ludwig's ten thousand dollars to after
you beat him today
oh i have to donate it to charity uh no
you don't know absolutely
i know i'm kidding i'm kidding uh i feel
bad just stealing 10 grand from him wait
am i
moving out of cam it's really zoomed in
you're a little crowded
we're going to fix it right now here we
go okay good yeah uh
saint judes why not cancer sucks
cool that's awesome
i uh i i we were joking off camera that
you'll maybe have
you have a lot of people rooting for you
today and obviously we love ludwig so we
like to tease him he's streaming right
now but
what how are you feeling about today
right you're making your pog champs
debut you've had some chess sessions
some coaching under your belt and
what are your what are thoughts what
thoughts are going through your head
right now
um well i i have a game plan
um i i i mean ask me afterwards
i feel more in depth but i i do have a
game plan
we'll see if it falls apart um
yeah we'll we'll just put it there okay
he does the same opening basically every
game he just yeah he's a one-trick pony
yeah completely whether i'm smart enough
or not to take advantage of that
we'll find out today well he spreads all
these rumors about his own
strength how do you feel about that his
bot um he's
created his whole cult of personality
are you buying any of that
uh yeah no he's pretty good i was i've
been watching a few of his streams uh
he he knows what he's doing i think
he'll be pretty competitive um i'm just
gonna do my best not to blunder
anything and like just completely screw
up that way
uh but i i think it will be a pretty
good game
speak of the devil i think we have some
is that the man did he join well um
jokes aside this is awesome of course we
wish you the best of luck and before we
let you go let me just say again that
um as when we when we invited you to the
event and you were on board what was uh
what was the biggest factor was it the
charitable element you want to get
involved we know your stream does
awesome things in that way or were you
just like everyone else fell in love
with the queen's gambit and beth harmon
and wanted to give wanted to give chess
your best chance
i i played chess a lot when i was
younger but i i stopped playing and then
like everyone else i'm ashamed to admit
i watched queen's gambit i got back into
it
uh honestly it just seemed like
something fun you know what i mean to
take my
my mind off of working and so i've
enjoyed practicing a little bit and i'm
excited
well regardless of how the match goes we
hope that's the interesting one it
continues
on social media showing everybody the
tweet right now you guys have had some
fun going back and forth
so our you know i know it's all in fun
and just my gosh oh there's the man
oh my god i thought we were about to end
uh-oh
okay first of all um can i call you can
i call you mister instead of mr beast
oh sure whatever you want whatever you
want
these chess.com clowns okay and let's
just call them what they are
feeding content hit me in the dms they
go hey
do you want to hop on to talk [ __ ] on mr
beast
bigger man i said no no this guy look
he's a little bit
nervous like come on busy man i don't
want to do this to him
come to find out you're on here talking
[ __ ] calling me one trick pony
all right at one point what is this what
is this mister
i thought we had a thing going on i
thought this was like a there's a
friendly mouth
what i didn't call you one trick pony
they called you one i did
it and you didn't call danny dumb and
stupid for it but she
is i mean to be fair yeah
we'll see okay what so
so like out of curiosity like what's
your real rating because like your
account you don't play a lot of games on
500 uh somewhere probably between 500
and 600
i don't know wait is it actually you're
baiting
you're i don't want to give away too
much i thought you were busy this was
supposed to be my freebie match
i thought you had like [ __ ] work to
do or something
17 youtube channels in like a food
facility have you been playing chess all
of a sudden
we'll see i i don't want to give away
too much the more i tell you
the more competitive advantage you have
jimmy this is the one match i wasn't
supposed to stress about i came in here
it's a [ __ ] meme
i put up ten thousand dollars i was
trying to bait you to put another 10k up
so i could get easy clap 10k
you didn't even fall for it i know i
noticed
ah okay but you're right here i i i will
put up 10k though
we're both throwing on 10k winner what
whoever wins not just one gimbal whoever
wins overall gets 10 grand i'll match it
wow sure yeah that's that's fine
[Laughter]
i guess i if he says it i didn't say it
that was just
me i like to make things more fun
yeah yeah though that would that i
that's that's crazy that would help
that's like 20 minutes of shroud's time
that's pretty good i'll take that
uh so well look i'm ready i played your
bot and let me tell you i
i stunted on your bot like you
[ __ ] on it i [ __ ] on your bot i i
checked
your body they purposely made them suck
wait why
debate me what is this misdirection
you're doing
okay that's fine i feel good about this
you know what
we'll see what happens here i i bet i
bet you
move uh your pond uh in front of your
king first
the e4 dude he's gonna psyche me out and
this is maybe his game plan he's gonna
make me play some dumb [ __ ] now
i'm going to play a terrible opening
line because he's
in my head this is like that one time
donya you'll remember when tall laughed
at world champion bobby fischer when he
wrote down a move he was going to do
and then bobby fischer decided to not
play that move and tall ended up winning
the game
yep but i still have bobby fischer
behind me
but i do remember that's historical
knowledge i see
yeah it's whatever oh jesus did you not
know about that
jimmy it was just a little bit of chess
history i've
been brushing up on might not be um the
most accessible
i read actually i read bobby fischer's
biography i i find him very interesting
i listened to the audiobook and i got
bored halfway through
same but i kept powering through because
i was already halfway did you read it
read it or audiobook it
audio uh yeah okay when i say read i
mean listen no one no
i do too i do too i just i would have
felt really dumb if you were also a book
reader
what i didn't think you had time to do
stuff i thought all you do is youtube
well you gotta turn your brain off
occasionally it's like
ninety percent of my life is youtube and
the other ten percent i'm like
struggling to find something
you got three youtube channels uh like
uh what do you call that a podcast all
right calm down we don't have you have a
girlfriend
you got how do you okay i'm over it i'm
over it i'm over it all right we'll just
see what happens on the planet
that's always a good community always a
good one
to cut off right there because i think
that what we wish both of you guys best
of luck i know i speak for everyone when
i say that
everyone will be rooting for you jimmy
um so
danny on robo for anyone else is just me
let's go for it go for it guys
you want a robo mo danny robo but what
you gotta fix your mic brother yeah
yep you want you want a robot as well
all right just has that effect on people
i'm down
are we playing now or do we go yeah
let's go let's get the world waiting
i'm gonna go
we'll see you on the other side as the
players get ready i want to give
one more shout out of course to grip six
not only are they sponsoring pogchamps
and you saw the belt earlier we also
have this incredibly
awesome custom made chess set they're
built as the only belt with no holes no
flap no bulk
made right here in the u.s of a go to go
to go.chess.com
grip6 to enter into the pot champs
ultimate giveaway and use the code
pogchamps20
or 20 off all of grip six products
they're
they're awesome i'm literally wearing
their socks right now i've really fallen
in love with their socks there's nothing
against the belt or the wallet but i i'm
a sucker for some comfy feet
and so i'm wearing them um and uh
on that note another thing another
reason to enter is you may win that
awesome custom chess set i've seen it
it's here in the office we'll be setting
up at some point so
dania don't go anywhere that interview
was awesome i'm even more pumped for
ludwig
versus mr beast we'll be right back
something's really off yeah we can't
hear you
it's not on mine right like you guys say
the same thing is it on the show
but zoom it's not on the show no it's
not on the show it's just the zoom
yeah zoom does that every once a while
remember we had that before
donya is it still acting up
yeah it's like chops
yo
mr b 6 000
all right time to get hyped
i'm a little nervous now i didn't i
didn't think he
i knew his account and i looked at it
and he only played like 20 games but now
i know he has a secret account that's
way higher rated and he also studied my
openings
and so my 10 000 easy clap w
might become another financial disaster
but the prediction is live gamblers on
my channel
so lay down the points if you believe
because i'm gonna try to roll this
[ __ ] and smoke them
take it down take the w
[Applause]
for all the [ __ ] on youtube who don't
have 50 million subs
[Applause]
and don't give to charity often
which i guess is most of us i don't know
he's like such a good guy so it's hard
to really
be mad at him but eat [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay i'm good to go
i'm good to go i'm prepped
i had the sickest mate i feel so good
because i had such a sick mate on his
butt
but it was his butt i just have to make
sure i put chat in a good place that i
can cheat from
uh that way if i'm in a tough spot i can
just look over
runches.com right now
kidding closing out of you right now
just a joke just a meme
just a meme is all just a fun little
joke
come on guys you know me just a fun
little meme amongst friends
[Music]
oh actually this is banger
hey here's i have uh one piece of advice
for mr beast and chess
my first pitch
why listen to me it's for you mr beast
i am a decently attractive dude
i play video game make million
and we are back here after what was
pretty awesome pregame interview there i
mean obviously ludwig almost took over
the show as he always does but i felt uh
i feel even more pumped for this ludwig
beast battle than i was before
i am super pumped as well after all that
talk we gotta have some
epic games to follow it up danny yeah
here they come
i'm uh i'm following lud skywalker his
chess.com username i mean when is he
gonna is he 12
i mean is he still naming himself after
star wars characters so anyway we got
lud coming up right now
well you know he studies tall games he i
think he's stuck in the past he's stuck
in the 70s i don't know if that's a bad
thing or a good thing
um he uh yeah trying to throw some shade
on beast obviously we know they're
kidding and they're and they're good
friends and it's a lot of fun
um and uh apparently now this game is
gonna work out even better than it could
have been for ludwig if he beats beast
he's got 10k
coming back to him because uh jimmy
ponied up there
that's i mean as if the trash talk
wasn't enough
we needed higher stakes uh i think this
is awesome i think the nerfs whoever's
nerves are gonna give out first that's
that's what's going to determine this
game yeah and
for those of you who maybe just tuned in
and i don't think so a lot of you have
been here we got
more than 70 000 on twitch and a lot of
other people everywhere else
but um budwig tweeted this morning that
he would give 10k to jimmy if he lost
and jimmy just matched the bet
so we got 10k on the line going into
their pockets we know that ludwig needs
the money
going broke over there uh jimmy not so
much
but uh but yeah it's all right games are
beginning right now here we go
and mr beast fog champs three presented
by grip six continues
and one e4 and mr beast is stumped he's
taking his time
he's waving that's a very rare move by
ludwig
okay scandinavian all right man
this just i'm gonna have to deal with
john bartholomew all over again the team
scandy hi guys
james candy here we go hey guys this is
john
all right we just play scandi here he's
gotten his
filthy hands on mr beast's opening
repertoire
he's playing fast too so who is the
better part of all of you impersonation
me or you
probably me
well you need to do more of it you can't
just say two words and then
uh have me award you the bartholomew
medal so
did you not john what do you think about
the scandy you've not seen my april
fools video
hi guys i stopped by starbucks on the
way all right
so really proud of this video and i
wanted to bring it to you guys because
it's about the hundred a game series
and uh okay
that was it was decent danny you know
i'll give you a b minus which is
in my in my book is a pretty good grade
all right but um
you know i've heard of better
impersonations to be completely honest
you're you are the impersonation king
so i'll let i'll let it be um all right
let's talk a little bit about the scandy
because if you again if you're just
tuning in
uh jimmy said he's been doing some prep
i actually know that he was doing some
coaching
earlier today before this i don't know
if i'm allowed to say which coach
maybe i am but he was doing some some
training and he said he didn't want to
go into what he prepared
he wanted to save it so here he's
busting out the scandy
and uh i don't know i think love might
be nervous let's let's listen into lud
and see what he's thinking about
so that would stop that as well uh
instead he attacks this
uh which is defended at the moment but
certainly could
be a tricky situation in the future uh
this was all for
a castle so castle i shall i also have
this threat though
so i'm actually just gonna be a little
prophylactic here maybe even a bit
cowardly
but i'm gonna play this move actually
doesn't really defend it though
i actually regret this a bit because if
he plays it if he might see if he sees
it
if he plays this and i take he wins
so i can't even it's not it's actually a
fake move
fake but that's fine he's laying a lot
of pressure here
typical scandy fashion he does decide to
castle queenside
uh i am going to push up this pawn now
uh understanding that
this bishop needs to leave and this
blocks any threat here
making this pretty much useless
and then i'm gonna probably go for a
d2 with my bishop looking at the queen
perhaps with the move like
i don't know knight over here doesn't
really matter i think
he's doing well describing his thought
process let's go so he's going to push
again maybe that's the idea
he's walking us through all the
launchers again and it's pretty good
logic
e5 though yeah that's not bad did have
some prep look at this scandy cause if
he pushes again here
and i take i'm threatened wallace
uh but it is attacked twice so i'm fine
as well so i'm gonna go here
sticking to the plan if he pushes i can
just take with my pawn
it frees it up to capture because my
queen is no longer being attacked by
this rook
wow castling is an idea i definitely
want to achieve at some point in my
lifetime
i don't know but i think jimmy was
feeling good we
we we had him off camera before but he
was smiling when he played e5 and kind
of rubbing his hands so we'll try to
listen into him when he
he starts talking but uh he he feels or
he he's emanating
emulating confidence here i think i'm
good i'm not worried
no cares in the world let's do it
okay
yeah he's just so happy i love it
well confidence yeah i know there isn't
that
maybe he's nervous but what's he gonna
do
oh boy
have i have i blundered yet uh have i
lost the game
nope there you have it taking some time
he's really thinking here look he's up
on the clock i might if you keep talking
about it
oh that's a dangerous smoke though gotta
move your queen
blood did say that he thought that
i think a lot of people have been unsure
about jimmy's strength right because he
hasn't played as much we haven't known
where he was at and so maybe that's why
ludd felt confident enough to throw the
10k on the line but
if jimmy plays some good moves out of
this opening he's definitely gotten
an advantage as black which is saying
something
absolutely and his pieces are active now
he's got to move his queen that's the
first step
and let's see how he manages to play now
that he's probably out of his
preparation he's got like you said he's
got to make a couple logical moves here
but ludwig is he's not in a terrible
shape but he's developed pretty
passively here
yeah but you're right he he he's not in
terrible shape especially if if jimmy
makes a false step with the queen here
god forbid he goes full bow test gambit
never go full botezz
ever that's what they tell you right put
the queen on a safe square like this
and you should be okay
completely and white can take black's
knight but then
that pawn from g7 can just recapture and
then black can use that file
and put a rook there and attack white's
king because ludwig is probably going to
castle
short at some point and it's going to be
a race of
who gets to the opposing king first
jimmy is uh gone into his first real
think of the game so whether he was
literally prepped before 94 which would
be incredible
or he just felt like confident enough
about the opening
he's obviously gonna gonna need to speed
up from here because he's going on two
full minutes having thought here
yeah and you know what concerns me danny
is the amount of time that he's thinking
because
uh if you identify the threat you maybe
spend a minute deciding where you put
the queen but okay
and he centralized that's a great move
seriously
fantastic um
i was highlighting queen b6 um but queen
d5
might have been even better honestly
this is this is a great move
especially if like dania said everybody
if the play switches somehow to the king
side
the queen will be so ideal here i mean
you can even play e4 right away but just
to highlight
what might happen with the queen and
rook working together so that would be
some coordination here
if if beast can can convert
the middle game advantage to a king side
attack that leads me astray
absolutely and in the early going
the time consumption is what concerns me
from both sides all right
they're already closed i don't think
we're wasting anything
obvious
now if he castles king side that's a dub
for us
i got my book threatening
pretty sure i can sound like an idiot
full disclosure i don't know what i'm
talking about
but i think he does i assume
i think he does mr mr beast is uh
playing like a beast so far let's listen
to ludwig see how nervous he is
yeah that music is so calming though
if he pushes though i think that's my
main concern
if he pushes and i
capture and then the queen
captures that gets a little bit monkas
but i think if he pushes i can just push
as well maybe hmm
or i can just stand my ground it's not
really a threat even though there's
three attackers because
the queen is in front of the rook so he
would lose a queen in this trade
i don't know if opting to castle is too
bitch-made i could also do this move
[Music]
if i go weakens the pawn defended he
can't go here
can't go here can't take
could go here
[Music]
that would kind of help him though no
no pretty good game right
[Music]
yeah but look at the clock with this
move
is that i'm no longer defending this
piece so if i go here
he could attack and it's only defended
once
but i would just take i'm gonna
i don't know if i'll regret this i
really don't but i'm gonna go with the
castle because i'm wasting a lot of time
gonna try to play a little bit quicker
because you only get five seconds per
move i think the last block chance was
fifteen
ten maybe ten ten maybe it's ten five
it was ten five just.com can i stop
getting front requests from me hermano
[Music]
so we'll miss you will he see
the way to get to white's king well
okay regardless of what happens here
beast has already impressed us
right donya i mean
i mean this is this is a high-level game
here and i'm impressed not only with
mr beast's preparation but how he's
followed that through he centralized his
queen
fundamentals now this is the pivotal
moment danny i really think that the
next couple of moves are going to decide
the game will mr beast
understand the area of the board that he
has to play on that is a king side he's
got to start attacking white's game
he's got to do it quickly both players
now down to five minutes
yeah and and i think we've been focused
on beast uh
you know maybe we know him a little bit
less than lud and all that stuff but
ludwig also gets a ton of credit i mean
he came out here
obviously against a well-prepared
opponent kind of surprised him
and his position is is totally playable
right and you see he was even
highlighting he he saw the drawback of
advancing the pawn to c4 he pointed out
that the d3 pawn would be weak
which was like also
also fantastic so yeah i mean um
but now okay now now beast is getting
down yeah he understands
yeah and that's now he's below five
minutes and ludwig understands the
danger which is a very important thing
if you're playing over confidently
uh you're much more likely to make a
blunder but i'm really really not liking
this this time consumption and he's done
look at him go
that is really impressive danny dude
seriously right he's playing all the
natural moves so
shout out to whatever kind of secret
training uh
jimmy's been getting on on the side
because he's clearly
clearly an underdog here uh surprising
people
he's he is under five minutes so if this
game continues with both them
you know playing the way they are we it
may just come down to time pressure
anyway which is
part of life right we don't play games
that have hours and hours on the clock
anymore at least not in these online
events
so uh we'll see but rook v8 what a move
that's a great move it pins the pawn we
saw charlie do something similar in
obviously in a different position but
the idea was the same uh in the future
you could slide your bishop over to h3
and attack that pawn because it's pin so
ludwig tries to preempt that but
he does weaken his king side a little
bit beast could still get his bishop
down at h3 that would be a great move
yeah but g3 was really good by lud right
i mean
it's anticipating just to show that if
if you waited with some random movement
bishop h3 came in everybody it's even
worse because
now when you push g3 the pawn is pinned
right you can't take
you lose the rook so so blood also this
is this is some high quality chest here
this is awesome i mean one of the things
i can say
we're only three days into pogchamps 3
presented by grip 6
but uh i think the chess has been
overall
maybe some of the best we've ever had
for sure in the ratings danny and i i
know you'll second me on this they don't
tell the whole story
you might look at the number and say
he's a beginner but beast is playing
some really high quality chess but this
will go down to a time screw but where
12 moves in and he's below four minutes
let's not forget they're not experienced
at blitz and bullets so
um if either of them gets down to a
minute that just might decide the game
unfortunately yep oh yeah
so nervous someone's going to get 10
grand in their pocket and it's not me
but one of these guys is going to lose
10 grand today
whoa e4 e4 that's another fantastic move
opening up the center he's got the and
london saw that possibility but it's
still a dangerous move
yep mm-hmm oh man
c4 counter-attacking the queen
about to get spicy everybody buckle up
yep the queen is attacked he's got to
move it
where does he move let's think from here
just back to b7 that's a big critical
over here
so there's only real tiles here
to which maybe i could go here
it's not defended though oh it is that
works
if he goes here i could go here
he could interpose but then i can take
protected
okay so interpose i just take
oh no i can't take cause the rook [ __ ] i
don't even see that
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] well that's fine
we'll wait for his move before we worry
about ours
the flag i still he interposes might
take here
because i still win a rook that's still
a win
i lose a bishop in a knight for a knight
in a rook so
that's not actually that big of a deal
[Music]
i'm not winning a queen boohoo
honestly i don't even know if it's that
bad to go takes takes two minutes
[Music]
that might even be good for him to be
totally honest queen sacrifice
oh did i blunder what no
no you didn't we talked about that
[Music]
um huh okay i'll do
this
he panicked that way i'm attacking if he
goes here i take this
exposing
[Music]
oh man that's unfortunate but it's how
some of these games have gone when you
see
players play really well and you think
their strength is better than it is and
you might you might see that
there's prep helping them and they're
getting positions they kind of
they feel good about but then having the
experience to play those and choose the
right plan in the critical moment is
another thing right and here jimmy
after playing like a like an absolute
boss like a beast
if you will he uh
he goes full bow test never do it
yeah and you can see in his face and
it's just body language uh he was all
smiles
he's feeling confident vibing and now
you can just see
the sort of he's not outwardly showing
anything but you can just tell
the disappointment and uh we can all
relate to that i mean we can no matter
what level we are we can all relate to
this feeling of
realizing that you had a good position
but you couldn't quite make anything of
it
yeah well it should give him confidence
right regardless of what happens in the
match
um that was an awesome start to the game
and he was playing quickly a fantastic
middle game and i think uh you know
it ludwig did the right thing when he
started kind of getting aggressive he
played c4
even if it wasn't objectively the best
he started attacking uh mr
beast and uh and that was the pressure
he needed so
i i i don't think that ludder's gonna
blow this at this point he's he's
improved so much as well
a lot like charlie from pogchamps one
right i just don't think that lobeck
doesn't win this game now
and i'm particularly impressed danny to
your point about his improvement
with his logic i mean he was spelling it
out for us yep uh he was
thinking some very high level thoughts
he was calculating variations not all of
his moves were great
uh but he was putting a tremendous
amount of thought into them so he's uh
he's definitely on the grind and it's
really impressive to see honestly
yeah for sure and uh i think one of the
most impressive things was that
was that uh ludwig played quickly enough
even though he was getting outplayed
so to speak right jimmy had a better
opening bloodwork was on his on his
heels a little bit
but he played quickly enough that um
that he was always in the game right and
i think that's a huge sign in experience
right i think players as they as they
play more
understand you can't solve every problem
on every move so you have to at least
give yourself a chance on the clock and
and then now now not only is he winning
but he's way up on time
yes and ludwig just did something
somewhat unnecessary he took
the bishop with his rook giving up an
exchange now it's understandable he's
trying to simplify
right he's trying to get pieces off the
board and it's kind of working
uh that wasn't necessary but it doesn't
ruin anything right
well beast grabs the pawn here oh that's
such a good move
that's a beautiful move let's listen in
on lubwig and see if he actually saw the
pin that he's gonna made him if he takes
the rook
king can't move oh wow he did so i
actually pinned his
wow bishop to a mate oh my gosh
and then i'll just do a little doubled
up file
and i'll still go for a big it's a
killer wallop dude i'm
super impressed by ludwig i obviously i
do as much as i can
to to bag on him on a regular basis
no you got to take your hat
check now he has to take i take with
check
um i hmm
i will form up this is flat out not a
battery i forget the name for this
uh we're very safe here using correct
gesture we can go either here he's not
actually attacking us so this is
pretty irrelevant we just check the rook
look at the confidence now
wow and now there is very little threat
for us to lose this game
um but we will try to
since he wants to keep going not that i
think he should stop but
uh we'll go here he goes down
if he goes down one then i just take it
he doesn't do that which is totally fine
um i will however go
i don't have a pin at the moment i will
check this way
danny this is textbook technique
it's gigi but maybe he finds something
[Music]
who is this impostor
all right game one win this is
oh my gosh this is just nastiness
who is this imposter and what i mean
with ludwig
this is ludwig kasparov ludwig tall he
was talking about those world champions
they'd be proud of him right now
unbelievable
uh all right well obviously we're gonna
take a very quick break before game two
begins super impressive
coming out of the gate by mr beast but
ludwig holds on
and takes game one can jimmy turn it
around with the white pieces
find out it's game two when we return
and i don't think there's a way out of
this well i guess i can just go here
right
yeah it's fine but i don't know that
seems pretty good for him i guess he
only has
yeah bishop takes yeah interesting
position
hey dude he [ __ ] he was cracked
nice no blunders but quite a few
mistakes
i don't feel bad about that though
you're gonna make mistakes when you have
no [ __ ] clue what the hell to do
i've never seen this opening played
exactly i've seen the scandy but i
i don't often see the scandy played with
uh
[Music]
a5
the pawn up i guess was the idea but i
hated the idea of pitting
i hated that but i guess there's nothing
to attack so this guy's
whatever whatever whatever whatever
he looked like an engine first 15 moves
i think he just prepared a line
and props to him because i think it's a
hell of a line
that was a really good line i thought
anyway uh how's it going let's double
check
let's double check double check double
check
there's only one real reason that you
try to beat mr beast
and it's for those sweet sweet
subscribers so let's get a live
subscriber count
real time ludwig versus mr beast
what do we have here shirley
shirley i am catching up
i have to be
let's take a look
any moment now you're about to start
seeing this number on the left just
rocket ship away
ludwig versus mr beasts you know it's
it's like pewdiepie versus t series
pewdiepie vs coco melon
pewdiepie picks a lot of fights
this is this is my moment
i think the website's a little slow it's
probably a bit slow
does anyone get to like refresh or
something
do i do diss track
it's not
probably broken website yeah you're
probably right
don't unsub from me after i beat mr
beast
what do you mean it's because you need a
diss track
okay all right all right yeah [ __ ] yeah
i got you um
rappy copyright free
oh no i got a better i got a better rap
beat
[Music]
eat [ __ ] [ __ ] you are bad i am really
good
that was all i had i didn't really think
too far into it i was
that's kind of a one bar song
sometimes it's good enough to have one
bar
sometimes you let the beat do the
talking you know what i mean
any moment now this should go skyrocket
tables are now open for gamblers by the
way you got a minute left for any
gamblers gamble away
[Music]
oh i'm live on chess.com again these
[ __ ] got no content on god hey
[ __ ] at chess.com what's up
it's ludwig you ever notice how they
always go to break and run ads and then
they use me for entertainment well
you can help out how so easy
let's talk about making your own hours
[ __ ] that nine to five [ __ ]
let your money make money how do we let
our money make money
introducing mogul moves that's right
if you twitch prime to me right now i'm
gonna be your friend
what does that get you some perks
friends with me means you're friends
with
cycuna corpse
slime what do those three have in common
not much actually but you'll be friends
with all
of them and all you got to do is twitch
prime
that's right click the subscribe button
see if it says subscribe free and purple
and if it does you're golden ponyboy
anyway let's check on who's priming
right now
oh [ __ ] it's my friend
um willis
hey willis can't wait to grab lunch
later catch you on the flippity flip
anyway back to the chest content you
guys have a good one
see you later
[Music]
i got like 200 primes it was a [ __ ]
smartest thing i've ever done in my life
i have so many twitch primes now
and there we go again enjoying the sweet
sweet sounds and video of ludwig at the
break uh but
now it's time to move on and get get on
to game two well
here's what i'm hypothesizing on
tanya if if jimmy's prep was this good
as black
getting a better position in the
scandinavian
and then finding having the knowledge it
seems to
to to also know how to approach this
middle game
the rook g8 move if his prep was this
good as black what's he gonna do is
white
this this is gonna be interesting
yeah and look i mean ludwig's gotta be
scared and one approach the ludwig could
take
is to brave something that he doesn't
normally play because it seems that
yeah beast got an amazing position and
if they get into something theoretical
you know beast could end up being
winning that's the danger of falling
into something like that when you're
black
right well i called him a one-trick pony
and he delivered
right no i'm kidding but he did he did
also get the win
lovely jokes aside he handled uh beast
prep
and then and then and then cleaned up
nicely that was impressive from lubbock
shows his experience and where he's come
which is really why we do the event it's
awesome obviously to grow the game and
to
bring the love of chess to a bunch of
different streamers and entertainers of
different categories
uh but watching someone improve like
ludwig has and how he like cleaned that
up with pre-moving his way to victory
that was badass that's all i'm going to
say oh good stuff
it was but what's not badass is the fact
that he's taking 30 seconds on move one
and beast
beast trotting out the d4 we don't see
that often in pop gems
i think lubbock's about to pull a
oblique the game has started
oops no maybe not he played d5
we saw we saw jimmy give a fist pump
there he was expecting d5 so we'll see
mcqueen's gambit
that might be a first chimp's history
uh he plays queen's gamut i ignore the
gamut [ __ ] that gambit no cap
[Music]
this dude's so cracked the [ __ ] is going
on this tournament
can someone be bad at the game i don't
need to defend this
[Music]
i could play maybe this move
it might allow him to do something like
this but i think that's fine
okay double defended
so good i could go here now what you
went you went to the dark side
best in small doses jimmy playing well
we're in it we're in a chagoran
decline which i don't think is exactly
what love would prep but for those who
speak
speak fluid chess knight to c6 is a
chagoran defense by black it's
not not that well known or common even
at the highest levels
um but then bishop five this this could
get spicy if beast is aware of ideas
that involve queen b3 right donnie if he
plays queen b3 at any point
taking advantage of the light squares
that'll really make me tip my hat to the
coaching and the time he's putting
because that would really show an
understanding of the dangers
developing the light square bishop in a
queen's gambit
and i'm already tipping my head i mean
i'm not wearing a hat but if i had one
and uh this is a very interesting
approach taken by beast he said he's
playing unconventional openings
um that he knows better than his
opponent now the problem danny with the
queen's gamut is that
it's it's not like the roof can come
down for ludwig even if he plays
inaccurately
the worst that's gonna happen to him is
that he's gonna end up being
you know slightly worse or even if he's
clearly worse there is no
attack on the horizon so he's pretty
solid here and beast developing his
bishop
no that's a really good point it's it's
not as dangerous as it was for him on
the white side of that scandinavian we
just had even though
uh beast wasn't able to convert on it it
was it was more potentially dangerous
this is going to be very solid i
totally agree with you um reminder to
everyone tuning in these guys threw down
a ten thousand dollar bet
started by ludwig on twitter this
morning and uh
beast backed it live in an interview
before the match started so there's a
lot on the line
what are they gonna do with that 10k if
it's going to go to charity you can
donate to charity use the command
charity command donate in in the chat
real quick
to get information because that'll give
you a link to the article where you can
see all the charities chosen by our
streaming
celebrities so if you are up for
donating obviously we have some big and
lofty goals we do appreciate it and use
the commands charity or donate to get
information
folsom a f my let's say okay i'm just
going to you're allowed to say af
but all right wholesome af
it means atlantic fried right atlantic
fried chicken
i thought it meant atlantic um
fog that's like a type of coffee and
yeah but atlantic now now that i'm on
the east coast yeah atlantic is would
say as
af a lot as af which makes
about as much sense as af so there you
go
um all right a6 andy6 played by lud a
solid move
faux show
just controlling some squares he he
likes to stop knight b5 mm-hmm
talk to any no you talking about explain
enlightenment you and i could talk and
not talk for hours that's the best part
about our relationship
indeed indeed and you know what i should
be
rooting for beast from the perspective
of i think that he
actually lives in north carolina so i i
think he's gonna win the state
championship pretty soon
i mean the way that he's playing right
now danny he's he's doing everything
right
is that a shade on north uh north
carolina chess or just
beast beast's ballardness
i mean north carolina chess is is in the
gutter basis
i was gonna say don't they have a
grandma no especially after that
horrible
i heard about it a terrible coach and uh
ruined the career of a successful
youtuber
you know yeah no it's just a sad sad
story indeed
indeed indeed we'll learn more about
that later
94 played by blood so he moves a piece
twice in the opening instead of
developing
for the kids watching that's a no-no
right don't do that get your pieces
developed
get castle but let's see what ludwig is
saying and how he justifies his current
behavior on camera dear god
i think what he might do is also bring
out the bishop
but that's fine for me i think
because if he brings out bishop
i might just [ __ ] pop this [ __ ] open
you know what i mean like this this
seems like a close position chest
music is growing at me he brings out
this bishop i take
threading the queen he has to take i can
take here he takes with the queen
i pop this bad boy out okay he does what
i want though
pawn or bishop i want the pawn to take
because i want to one make sure that
this is dominated by me
and two i want to keep this tension
and i also attack this which can be good
um for me
so now we're bad boy out with a hope to
castle he'll probably do something
similar with his bishop maybe he brings
it out here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
super impressed with beast and impressed
with ludd i'm this is awesome
seriously go ahead daniel
yeah no we're not just saying it i mean
uh the thing is
most of these players are familiar with
e4 openings and for them to play
high level chess after one d4 in a
position they're less familiar with is
uh is is amazing that's it's awesome and
you know what else is awesome danny
is all those donations coming in uh we
really appreciate it this is great to
see
yeah uh we gave a uh an organic call to
action because we were speculating one
of these guns is going to do with their
10k
uh remember there's 10 000 on the line
that they threw down
this morning but um really really do
appreciate it obviously we're going to
continue to see that we know that some
of the players have even been public on
social media that they're going to
donate their winnings to charity
i know uh my boy bobby logic said that
on his twitter account
last week um and so it's awesome it's a
big another
a big part of why we're doing this so
thank you again of the community now
now we'll focus on the chess and
appreciate all the donations coming in
um all right 95 so
beast kind of meets ludwig's night
knight e4
and says i'll raise you one and also
move my knight twice in the opening
and again the main thing i think is that
either
player probably should have just
developed and gotten castled a more more
principled thing but
i also kind of like that they're both
being aggressive and looking for an
opportunity here i mean if if beast
takes with the bishop
we have a borderline symmetrical game
here of good chess by both sides
you know what's hilarious let me blow
your mind for a second if white takes on
e5 of the bishop which i assume mr beast
will
please don't take with the pawn and ruin
this and then if ludwig plays c5
we literally have an a yeah so if ludwig
plays c5 here it is literally
symmetrical to the
to the last pawn now we'll do that
i don't know he won't i think he'll do
it just for the kicks and gigs of it
that that's
you know lug is used to throwing for
content no he didn't okay never mind
all right 56. it would have been a
terrible move it would not have been a
terrible move
but this is this is double edged by
itself i'm not saying
this is even the best move objectively
but grabbing this pawn
is super dangerous right um beast
could even look to play moves like queen
h5 or queen g4
this is this is spicy and these guys are
both dead luck on the clock i think mr
beast is saying hey i'm not i'm not
going to be the weakest player in this
group like maybe a lot of people thought
i might be
right no and and we've seen that from a
lot of players so far like i said
ratings don't tell
the whole story we even saw that uh
danny as far back as as
pogchamps one we saw people like i don't
know why i remember him specifically but
someone like slicker
who you know you're rating maybe 500 but
listen listen
listen listen listen
uh he was actually pretty good so bishop
takes g7 beast going
for it that was a pretty good little did
you just post out a mini slicker
impression that no one saw coming
yeah i don't really practice it but you
know cut me some slack
i'm just looking for an excuse to do
more impressions most of the things i
remember about slicker from pog one
cannot cannot be talked about although
who am i kidding we have the parental
advisory below chess tv for a reason
reminder if you're watching there is a
parental advisory there you know what
show you're getting into welcome to
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
here we go uh rook rook to g8 um
so lud does the right thing on bishop g7
bishop e5
is kind of the only move or the best
move but
man this is about to get about to get
real spicy i think
yeah so the bishop is hanging right
bishop has to well probably
mr beast will move the bishop he might
move it back to e5 and then ludwig
has his sights aimed at that g2 fun but
he's got to be very careful
because if he takes that pawn he might
actually get pinned by white stroke so
there's a lot going on here and ludwig
might choose to prioritize his
development
which is what i would do yeah
oh
it's not the worst move from an idea
perspective everyone because he's trying
to trade bishop for bishop right and and
that's a lot of times where the
calculation stops but
the reason donde and i both grimace is
because if lugwood goes all the way
to see queen h4 check at the end of the
line things could get
to get really interesting here um and
ludwig might already be looking at a
check like that let's let's take a
listen in
and see what lud is thinking about this
pawn i take here
i literally did the wrong one i
literally said out loud what i was going
to do i think this is fine though but
[ __ ] but
obviously i just talked about [ __ ] up
the structure
[Music]
frustrating frustrating to play bad man
[Music]
now the check will be very strong on h4
in here i could do a tactic though
that's the kind of awesome things we do
on the fly my team letting me know yeah
cutie's cheering on her man and my
producer that's right making it happen
right on my cue look at that cutie's got
commentary going and now she's going to
mirror herself it's going to be awesome
let's watch it
look at that right on my channel look at
that he's got commentary on it now she's
going to
take me off your screen this is so
embarrassing
i'm not wearing makeup and i'm eating
cheese this is not please
go to twitch.tv slash cutie cinderella
chat everybody here
go to twitch.tv cinderella and hit the
follow button
down there before she
um okay and she ain't too shabby herself
okay she's working on her chest too all
right we're back seriously she's awesome
if you haven't followed her channel
go go give it go give it your follow
alright g3 was played this was the line
i was predicting
right with with uh queen h4 check john
did this is oh he finds bishop takes g3
even better
the brook is hanging wow i mean it's
just crazy
and that is just devastation being
reeked upon black sting that was
the whole point of queen h4 check and
you can just tell by his eyes he has his
eyes are aimed
right at white's king right at white's
king's side and
despite the best efforts of mr beast i
mean blood is just
he's earning this one danny he's got to
take our hats off
he's played so well and i i i don't want
it to be the story line i want a bag on
blood i can't wait for that no i'm
kidding no i i love the guy and this is
this is his chest
look how good he's gotten here i mean he
doesn't even settle on queen e4
he sees the pin takes on g3
and and this is just an awesome thing to
see where he's uh
he's gonna go to and jimmy has played
super well mr b says
has surprised and had obviously some
some
great ideas his openings were good but
ludwig just right now just that much
that much better
absolutely and you know miguel tall
right whom ludwig tries to model his
games after you know who
his favorite uh music musical composer
was
he was asked once and in a fit of
inspiration he said
ludwig van beethoven
yeah that was i was i was cooking that
up for hours danny
dude so this is my moment in the sun
there's a reason we have bad pun
emotes for you like on multiple channels
well i gotta live up to my name i'm
literally the punchline i haven't been
awkward
i'm the punchline of the most awkward
cringe-worthy moments we've ever had in
chess but you dude you just jumped into
the top five with that
that was awesome ugh
i'm if i make another bad pun my hair
myself might start falling out and then
i'll need a blood wig
who do you want to thank for these i
mean that was pretty good i'm just
oh i'm dying inside and this is my job
to make people feel this way bro
wow who do you want to thank for for how
far you've come with your bad pun game
it's you know it takes a village danny
it takes it takes many people
to allow me to descend to such to such
depths
it's really it's taken many years of
practice
all right well um well
what's going on here budwig is playing
fantastic chess he won the exchange with
bishop takes g3
a five head tactic cleaning up now
even plays queen takes e4 here which i
think is even better than taking i mean
g3 is also on the agenda but i like that
he gets the queen into a strong position
he's playing some of the best chess i've
ever seen him play
seriously yeah he's playing amazing and
look at the time consumption he's not
playing too fast but he's not playing
too slow he's got half his time left
and unfortunately beast one of the
things that brought him down is
just you know he's got a minute on the
clock and uh for
i mean beast is is very very impressive
and he's going to train a little bit
more danny
he's going to have a serious shot at
winning some of these uh future matches
yeah and maybe the whole event i mean
obviously we've been talking about who
the strongest
players are um super
super hard to predict right now but i
mean this is this is the kind of chess
that
it gets you pog champs belts yep
that's just although i'll say this if
ludwig wins he might be the one person i
refuse to send this to
i'd lock it up make him come get it
himself
right absolutely make a cross-country
trip out of it
all right queen takes g3 you know just
like beth
wow yep check king has to get out this
is this is a massacre
black is not actually up we'll back us
up in exchange in a couple pawns but
more importantly is the time situation
you know what would be a pretty uh
pretty cool move here danny
castle's long okay he just keeps getting
checks
castles long would be the uh the right
way to bring this thing to a close for
sure
the middle of the heated attack terrible
how could he miss that
[Music]
defended defended here must interpose
oh that worked out well
i would say so pre-move it because i
think it's forced
oh my god it now goes too much
uh we're checking again here next level
stuff
and we'll check again here grab pawn
like i said too much among us who is
this imposter
uh we're going for a mate there's a bad
fun for you how's that
the bullet world champion
[Music]
wow instant chess
wow mopping it up here
oh my gosh
[Music]
um holy [ __ ] sick oh my lance
oh let's go dude never have i felt so
good on a chess board i've i felt so
calm today that was great that was good
chess
oh yes it was
i'm speechless oh my lens i'm speechless
my my throat is dry a lot of people
said that brain wilson was maybe
the clear favorite to win but you know
what dwight schrute has to say about
that
because i could use some nice gaia key
for mate
it totally use some of that as well to
enjoy with some of the park champions
just made a statement and said rayne
wilson is not the favorite and pog
champs will be presented by grip six
white fruit says false and we'll be
right back
come
you win this
oh i mean poo whoops sorry chest viewers
my bad
behave yeah my bad my bad my bad pg-13
hey chess people are you ready to watch
our matchstick against
is it bad if i just insta forfeit two
games in a row
no well that's why that's why you're
a big gaping whiner no you're a racist
nice
yo 127. what do you mean let's count
from the front
all right guys come on bye around and uh
let's pick it up
i'm gonna start working long from now on
yo do you still play omen not really
because kiljoy's meta so i play brim
if i need a blind pick you want to hear
my omen impression
snuff them out
lick my nuts
[Music]
i didn't hit him at all needing him
one enemy remaining where's jed i want
satchel last guy i think would mark it
hold on nice job everybody
there is yo how big are my eyes
what how big are my eyes uh they're
they're just i don't know as bad as a
monster
i'm just not gonna talk about eyes
anymore because i understand that's a
sore topic for all of you
what are you talking about literally
nothing
i'm just saying raise just stop
i will i don't [ __ ] trust me
oh okay i got you i got you
to flash pipes jet is in ct careful
wait that's not pipes uh one trouble
you didn't you know you didn't pop it
right yeah i know i [ __ ] think
thank you
did you see that post on reddit gold yes
hook it up bro watch i'm gonna fake
flash i'm gonna all and then i'm gonna
fake flash okay
all right all right all right
one showers oh they're like
heaven omen is heaven a heaven
close he's there heaven
he's triple
[ __ ] leg
someone random in your chat but if you
want charity that's not [ __ ] them
yeah give it to charity my chat's going
to be so sad right now
they probably just blogging out of their
mind nah [ __ ] them on god they're good
they're good
they're good you heard it here first
folks [ __ ] his chat
[ __ ] my chat hey they know i'm the one
who says it to the most
but uh either way my man um hype games
i think i think your path
is just easy crushing the consolation
bracket
which is where all the hype is at anyway
from my experience
uh yeah well yeah that's a nice way of
saying i suck
but no danny will danny will back me up
here going to the losers bracket
was a decision i made in the last pog
champs
all the good players and he almost won
yeah i lost to charlie in the finals and
it had more viewers than the winner's
bracket because no one gave a [ __ ]
because it has like irrelevant streamers
like you know
uh i'll do some call outs sure sardoche
uh
daniel negranu the [ __ ] is that boomer
uh
you're uh doing the lord's work you're
making sure you get to the finals so
i have to go to the finals because i
have a chess coach and he would
beat my ass if i didn't go there so this
is purely
for hey i went up against the man with
the chest coach
i enjoyed this next year here next year
can you put it where i play him again
first round if we both make it next year
i'm down next year i will train i'll
give myself a chest coach
i'll learn your first seven moves not
your first six i'll go all out
that's gonna be the game changer all
right one year one year from today
we rematch in chess and we uh we put we
put we put high stakes on it
i'll give you my stream key and you give
me your just give me your youtube
channel
oh uh yeah you can have like the
reaction channel
this is getting next year we've got
channels with 10 mil bro
we've got pogchamps coming up we'll do
another one later this year so
uh but anyway guys uh
almost almost 99 of that golden banter
was was off stream but we caught the end
of it i heard
you say ludwig you're going to donate
your 10k to charity or beast can choose
the charity of his choice
oh you guys were offline well we were
online on my editing reels were offline
yeah i
i don't want mr beast to give me 10k i
wanted to go give it to charity and go
make another hype
but you forgot the most important part
though he specifically said
[ __ ] his chat yes
he did offer the money to my chat and i
said [ __ ] him on god and i hope
by that statement okay well before your
eyes everybody you can see all the
charities that our streaming celebrities
have chosen so there are some
really specific ones that are based on
their local community and kind of really
near and dear in their hearts there are
some
more well-known um global charities
there we see mr b security st
jude's obviously we're raising money you
can use the charity command
or the donate command in chat we do
appreciate all your love and it's all
gone
um okay back to the chess uh mr beast
that was that was no that wasn't
what you said no just start it was epic
you were
i mean donya and i were blown away by by
the opening prep
and then i heard you say to ludwig you
know off off stream here that you
literally he's like a
he's more than a one-trick pony i mean
you could download his games and you've
got a map to victory right
but then what happened for you after the
openings where you really started to
take a lot of time
and then you weren't sure what to do
right yeah so uh like i was saying to
his stream but for the people who are
watching on the chess stream um
i basically just looked at all his like
recent 50 games and just
he does the same thing every time based
on how you respond so
i had i practiced with my friends i was
like just do this when i do this and
so like i practiced like 50 games like
the first six moves
but i never played past that part and so
that i just kept
i was like all right we're gonna get
here and then every time we got there
from that point on i just fell apart
every game because i i don't practice a
fraction as much as he does he's
obviously the better player
next year whenever we do this again
though i'm really gonna i'm gonna get a
coach and take it seriously
but you you got pressured obviously by
his prep
but then you held on because obviously
we were really applauding jimmy's
uh preparation and his approach at this
point but even more impressive was the
fact that you kind of handled this and
you didn't get down on time and you you
kept your head so what were you thinking
did you kind of you smelt a rat that he
was prepared but
what was going through your head me
yeah oh dude game one so back up a bit
if you go to like i forget the move but
i felt like he could have gone knight a
similar trick i did earlier
to b4 and i was stressed out about that
and then when i attacked his queen
uh a little bit later uh i was also
stressed out
that um that he would just take with his
pawn and ignore his queen
and then he would fork my queen and rook
and i was stressed out about that
this position here yeah i kept getting
into ugly situations
and all i said to myself i was like damn
hope you don't do that
and he did it and he did it and he ended
up thankfully just uh giving away the
queen here but
uh he found himself in a beautiful spot
here i felt like [ __ ] i mean if he just
took with that pawn there
that knight that bishop and i i get a
queen from it but i lose three minor
pieces that's
uh not that great it's equivalent in
points but it's pretty down in terms of
uh
his attack that'll have on me i felt
really bad but thankfully it's not what
happened
yep but thankfully i suck yeah
well i think i think shockingly i think
uh
you are like really good positionally
which is like weird
and i am only good like tactically and
so you always got in better positions
but i just don't think you had like
the uh which i think is just a practice
thing straight up i think you know
if we combine our talents we make one
decent chess player
yeah if yeah that's what i'm saying
that's i'm going to secretly wiretap you
in
on a zoom call for every future chess
match to hopefully help you be happy
beat everyone but then you had a great
position
again as as white uh and so what was
what was the prep here right we saw that
you got a great position and ludd by the
way
that's some five head analysis i mean
dude you're literally
seeing the board super well because
you're totally right he could have he
could have gone for this and he didn't
so in the next game you also had some
prep
mr beast but where where did it go wrong
here or where did you not know anymore
uh in terms of what he was going to do
uh
so if you just i can tell you just
rewind it to the start what color am i
white i could literally so i i go d4
first and then he always mirrors it
yeah and then then i moved my uh yeah
that pawn
and then he always moves one of his
knights out and then i i move one of
mine
and i'm pretty sure his next move is to
move a night out right
right or that hurt and he likes yeah
and he likes to uh then i probably moved
my other night and then he likes to move
his light
square bishop out somewhere so cold out
right now
and a lot of the games i saw he would
put it on d7 but i
i was whenever he did this he would put
it there um and now i'm starting to draw
a blank it's easier to remember when i'm
like actually playing
um but yeah you can like get to this
part and i asked like uh
gotham i was like is this good for me
and he's like yeah this is a good
position
and so i was like all right i made it my
objective just to get this board right
here
and then um yeah just keep developing
pieces so i can castle
danya after that nice for jimmy the next
time he gets this against ludwig
well i think one thing you could do is
you could take that pawn if we
actually go back to the very beginning
after knight f6 move two
taking the pawn on d5 is a good idea
piece and then following up by
controlling the center with e4
um what do you have to say to that
ludwig is your eskian game manual
helping you deal with that
uh yeah because i would go back
and then you know what here's my take i
and this is why i play the same thing
every time openings are [ __ ] and no
one gives a [ __ ]
as long as you get all your pieces out
and you control the center
right no one here is good enough to hold
the lead we saw
rayne wilson choke 18 different ways
so as long as i don't make a giant
blunder if positionally i am down
because there's one theoretical line
where if donya was in this spot he would
walk
down to this win i'm fine
so i my thought process was hey let's
just get my shits out let's just do my
thing
i will say what it did screw me on was
time oh my god
i was so slow i was molasses because i
had to think really hard
but uh i i wasn't i wasn't too worried
as long as i didn't make a giant mistake
well let's talk about the time you play
i was i was singing your praises even
though it was against every fiber of my
being
my being i was singing your praises and
i was saying that one of the things you
get credit for is that when he kind of
out prepped you
you you handled the clock super well you
never got way down on time
was that a conscious effort are you
working on that like what what was the
deal
it was way down on time and then i was
like i gotta go faster and so i just
started planning out moves but they
weren't good ones so like that's like
where i ran into the bishop attacking
queen
i planned that attack but it wasn't a
good attack and i knew that but it's all
i could think of
and so uh same with when he took uh game
two
bishop and then he went to uh take the
pawn on
what was it like g7 whatever that is
uh and i brought my rook out i thought
that was all so bad because it
you know it didn't it worked out
tactically because i had a few things
that happened but
i was i don't think my moves were good i
just had a plan and i stuck to it and i
tried to play quick
you did it at the end we were impressed
with your speed and your accuracy at the
end whatever it is you're doing
maybe you are cracking open doretsky's
engine manual keep doing it but
not to take anything away from you that
was a great opening great play all
around
yeah beast young god young guy i don't
know how you have the time man
oh anyway now that you followed me on
twitter i'm gonna dm you daily for
advice on thumbnails
let's do it what what's your next video
or actually i probably probably don't
want this on a chest stream
youtube strategy my next video is how i
beat mr beast for ten thousand dollars
uh
oh that's a banger he carves most of
your videos him [ __ ] on me in chess
wait really yeah yeah interesting
interesting ten thousand dollar things
that happen let's bring it up
you want to put a picture of me like
about to cry in the thumbnail because
then people will think i'm like pissed
off
all right yeah we'll help carl bully you
for a while
well you guys uh you added the stakes
and um
i know it's a lot of fun in games but
seriously i mean it's another ten
thousand dollars to charity big reason
why we're doing this you guys are
awesome
thank you um jimmy i know i know you're
going to keep working on it and jokes
aside seriously that was super
impressive and i agree with ludwig i
don't even know that it has to be in the
constellation bracket i think you're
i think your pogchamps future is bright
bud i i don't know what to say man i i
don't know who you are anymore
like who is this imposter like what is
going on with you
just keep doing it i guess just studying
a bit
here and there all i gotta say is one
final message to chat
if you guys go out and beat danny's bot
on chess.com he'll give you a free
diamond membership if you screenshot it
instead of proof
everybody let's do it no one can do that
and everybody's already beaten your bot
and they've sent it to me i got so many
diamond memberships i got to give away
is ridiculous
dude my butt trash what do you want from
me just says the plan is simple
and then chokes all right well this
isn't over
all right guys all right good luck guys
later everybody you're awesome thank you
guys pleasure to see you we'll see you
in your next match thanks
all right that was awesome all right
indeed that was crazy high quality chess
and
if only we had one more matchup danny
but
wait we actually we do
yeah i mean honestly what you said is
true that uh
the chess was awesome and shout out to
to levy rosman i didn't know if i was
allowed to say that he was he was uh mr
b's secret coach but then
uh jimmy revealed it himself he worked
with gotham so in addition to apparently
doing a good strategy what do you think
about that strategy john
of play having your friends play a bunch
of games with the opening moves of your
opponent
right which is how he helped apparently
that helped him memorize in addition to
working with levy this morning
which is awesome um i i think that
jimmy's future in this event may
surprise people especially after what we
just saw here
that's some next level scouting that's
uh you know russian grand master kind of
territory and uh
his own players are awesome he's showing
well he's getting there though i mean he
he predicted what ludwig is going to do
he's better out of both games so
uh he's definitely going to say going to
make his presence felt this pock jams
and he's going to be a fixture
uh for sure as he gets more training it
yeah uh for sure and and it was awesome
i can't wait for both of them to play
their next masters but we also have one
more match today
don't go anywhere chat pog champs three
presented by grip six continues in just
a few moments
introducing the grip 6 belt the only
belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip 6 is so
light and thin that you'll barely even
notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes
this belt the most comfortable belt in
the world
overly confident much you're damn right
because on top of being the most
comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear
and damn tee
meaning if you don't like any belt for
any reason at any time or in any
condition
you can just contact us and we'll give
you a full refund
welcome in guys
i know we're go i'm going up against the
top seed in our bracket right now so
it's like oh
we're gonna try to do our best that's
what that's our focus
do our best for today's match
do our absolute best
[Music]
[Music]
um
oh okay
you got that [ __ ] don't worry i'm ready
i mean i'm not i'm gonna try my best
we'll see what happens we're gonna try
i'm gonna try
my best
i like to move
awesome different music real quick
oh boy
did you get another lesson with maurice
i did a little lesson with maurice after
our first one
but other than that not really
um no okay
there we go
reach deep into yerba mate culture and
you discover
people have long gathered to imbibe mate
to awaken the mind
perform extraordinary feats and exchange
confidences
brewed from the naturally caffeinated
and nourishing leaves of the species of
holly native to the south american
atlantic rainforest
come to life with guayaqui's wide
assortment of
yerba mate offerings all with powers to
unite
and energize
and we are back here we've had a lot of
new subscribers today thank you for that
support
um and it also gives you access to the
gaia key emote
in chat and if you didn't know ayaki
there yerba mate
is celebrating 25 years as your favorite
regenerative
beverage they're sharing cases to
celebrate they're not kidding i've got a
ton in the office and i poured it into
my
white fruit mug and damn was that stuff
delicious it doesn't have corn syrup i
don't know if you know that i'm an
anti-corn syrup guy
i freaking loved the gaia key or bramate
and i'm gonna keep drinking it
and a lot of our players and
commentators have gotten some too so you
can get some cases if you spam the
emotes but you got to start doing it
right now another thing we're going to
do right now
is talk about hand in brain dania
naraditsky what's your favorite part of
hand and brain as a format
what i love the most is uh when
one person very vehemently wants one
move and then the other person plays
another move
and that anger and suppressing that
because you got to keep the chemistry
going you can't just yell
at someone and what i also love is the
person playing a different move than
originally intended but that move turns
out to be better so
right there's so much that's really cool
about that dynamic
no i love that you just said that the
biting of the of the tongue so to speak
when like you don't want to ruin your
chemistry with your
you know higher rate or lower rate of
partner so you don't get you don't get
pissed but
you're clearly unhappy um but uh anyway
that's awesome just a reminder the
twitch rivals event on march 2nd will
have 35
000 in prize money homie um a lot of
your favorite streamers both of the
variety
and other game category and chess will
be in it budwig boy boy our first ever
pogchamps champion will be back
motez live at hicarro are involved all
kinds
of awesome chess streamers and members
of other categories like i said so mark
your calendar for march 2nd
all right donya myth and
a guy that has come out of nowhere and
been on the grind
establishing himself as maybe the
favorite to win it all in in the french
streaming sardosh and then you've got
myth
who's getting better with every show he
started doing lessons with maurice
ashley
um your thoughts on the matchup we're
about to see
well definitely sardosh pulling pulling
ahafu he's been
grinding i mean the legends have been
going around
uh but obviously i wouldn't sleep on
myth i mean we've already seen this
play out again and again uh it's easy to
underestimate someone when
uh you've got his opponent grinding like
sardoch does he's
clearly the favor danny i think there's
no denying that but i think the game
you know when the bright lights are
shining uh the game is often
closer than uh you know it seems to be
on paper
yep no and that happened in the first
match with nico sardoche
um ultimately did prove to be the better
player you know he
he got the the w but nico um hikara and
i
were saying i mean she had some moments
where her intuition her feel for
for certain things was not only spot on
but her speed was super impressive
maybe it actually kind of backfired if
she had slowed down a little bit with
some of the advantages she had
sardosh maybe not you know maybe not uh
have walked away with a victory there so
um so yeah i think uh i think myth knows
he's the underdog but he's here to
continue to rock and get better he's
enjoying it
and sardosh sodosha admitted he was he
was nervous
after that uh after that um first match
with nico so he knows there's a lot of
pressure on him
and yeah all right we uh we're a couple
of minutes away from game time
[Music]
your thoughts on your mate yeah it's
your point about pressure this stuff all
the time i'm just getting into it i had
no idea
i've i've been having for years actually
um truly and
i like the taste it's uh it's pleasant
and uh
people on my stream know that i don't
you know i don't give my approval to
something that i don't actually like
uh and also it has the word mate and in
many languages
obviously that means nate so you gotta
drink
something that contains the word mate so
grand master approved
your puns are just i mean i'm so past
the point of cringing i'm like
i'm just impressed
i mean it's uh it just comes naturally
you know it just comes
it's it's my greatest talent
let's see shall we say well now that's
too
i was going to include the name myth but
um
yeah it's it's it's as stale as a can of
star sardines or sort of star doge
or doughy i just i need to i need to
stop start talking
i've struggled with how to say his name
a lot uh sardash
yeah french not my
specialty yeah but sardo sounds pretty
natural
yes it's easier for me to speak american
um it's english but okay russian media
but easier for me to say russian names
but okay french is not so easy
um all right well the uh the chat is
ready we've got myth in his normal
streaming setup where his fans have
grown to know and love him
dardoch is um sometimes he gets so
focused he goes full fobby full fabiano
where all we got is the forehead and the
hairline
i'd never go full fabi fobby
but
they become close yeah wow
and uh that's he is a grinder and you
can see his rating here
wow that's he's almost 1400 danny that's
pretty darn impressive he is pulling a
happo by the way
apparently the reason why the games
haven't started is because sardoche
started a practice game which is why
we're tuning in to watch because
that is actually his live game
oh wow you can't get enough training
smith is like i stopped my games and
then he started one
what is going on
this is crazy he's not doing too well
here but he's getting the
the l's out out of the way
uh he's almost 1400 rapid
is
guy is put in the time
oh he's going to get checkmated though
yeah if 68 is found it's it's it's rover
red rover
and yeah he's just got to get the
blunders out of the way
yeah he's going to resign oh i like it
all in french
whoa he's starting another game oh did
you start another game
someone go aborts okay good the staff
reported did he play the game
danny did i just see somebody shut down
that man's ability to start games
there we go i love how we keep aborted
oh now we started the myth game
okay there we go nice game on
guys you're right it was just i gotta
get another game i gotta get another
game
oh yeah that was
all right yup but he plays the grub now
that is
we'll see what he does with white now
he's uh sort of playing black here myth
is white
and an open sicilian day okay
i'd rather have it open sicilian than a
close sicilian i say
um i don't know where that came from
and no that was a very wise statement
i'm still
you know i'm still considering its
implications and and orf
played by sardosh and the knight of is
sort of a big boy opening
it's just not something you waltz into
if you haven't studied openings
it's very theoretical you got to know a
lot of stuff and
uh e6 he's playing it professionally
so far after seeing the first one
and i know that nico uh he held her own
in that match
ultimately got the draw in the end um
but seeing
seeing some of the tactics that sardosh
unhurled
this rook takes g2 thing um
and and just the way he's playing this
opening here i mean i don't think
there's any question anymore as far as
time this guy is putting in and how
strong he is
yeah for sure and these pawns on e6 and
d16 are called the
kevin ingen structure i think it's named
after a a city i think in the in the
netherlands where
and you'll see that some openings and
structures are named after cities and
usually that's because uh there was a
tournament held in that city
where that particular opening was was
sort of first played
but i'm actually impressed and i don't
mean to sound like a broken record but
i'm honest here myth is developing his
pieces in a really nice way he's
positioned his pawns kind of like a
vampire teeth
clamping down on the center but and
there it is jinx may strike again i'm
not a big fan of that one
yeah i agree with you um i was about to
compliment in the same way and highlight
that you talked about the chevron ingot
structure if we talk about myth
structure this is known as a
meroxybind structure clamping down like
you said particularly on the light
squares
if method just played knight c3 and a
lot of the moves here are very natural
you put the rooks in the center the
queen finds any number of squares
and white typically has an edge just
just like the the eval bar says
queen a4 is one of those moves that
sometimes happens for inexperienced
players where after doing the logical
things
they they want to be all right well now
i got to go do something got to be
aggressive
i think it takes a while for the
patients to to come in where you realize
actually doing something good is
sometimes just building your strength
developing your pieces
behind your furthest advanced pawns and
not having to look to to make
aggressively you know optically
aggressive looking moves so
anyway but i do like the last couple
moves by myth and i think we have a very
equal middle game ahead
we absolutely do he dials it back which
is good makes sure that all his pieces
are safe now so i know she's probably
going to develop his knight he's got one
more piece left to develop and
my guess is he's probably attracted by
knight g4 no he develops his knight
uh and then he might bring his rook into
ca and x-ray the queen that would be
one way the plaque could continually put
pressure on white center now
black is cramped but that's kind of the
point you don't have to have a lot of
space in chess
to have a good position black's got a
lot of ways that he can break through
and uh white's pieces could end up being
overextended
very well said and i think this is a
critical moment so let's let's go in and
see how
mr tsm myth is doing in terms of what
he's thinking about
[Music]
fascinating
okay are my headphones working
focused yes
it's a weird game
hey he said something very very
tight-knit here
like i wonder when this is all going to
explode you know
okay maybe that's when all right maybe
maybe the time is soon
he understands that this is intense this
position
is wow
and decide knight d2 would be better but
the reason is kind of complicated
oh i just did it
but now sardo says this move knight to
a5 knight to the side attacking the
queen
queen has to move and then you win that
pawn on c4
yeah he will he find what was the best
move several moves if he had played
knight c3
but the position got specific enough
where the knight on d2
was the better square but i don't know
that sardo should have seen
a five pawn i move my bishop here
there's no threat
right you might play knight e5 instead
he might want to go to the center
but he does get the move back it's not
like a crazy thing
but it does help advance i think
i think i want to go for a palm break
here it's just so intense danny
e5 oh okay he's he's trying to go for
the first one
that shows you let's come back to the
board here i mean that that shows you
even even though sardoce has been
applauded for the night orphan obviously
one of the stronger players maybe the
man to beat
this shows you that even for him donya
once he did the opening correctly
kevin ingan his lack of experience right
there's only so many book smarts you can
have right your actual experience is
another thing
it's hard to know what to do with these
pawn structures because
often here for black as well he should
have been patient or found your 985 move
and just built strength it's hard to sit
on a center sometimes
as you're learning the game and e5 was a
potentially a very bad move because of
these light square problems here for
black
yeah you're you're absolutely on the
money danny and
that as you said is the danger of
playing these openings
where you have to think creatively in
order to play well and i love
what myth did here knight to f5 he's
playing aggressively purposefully
and that d5 square is indeed very very
weak now sardoche
i mean he doesn't have to take the
knight but it probably would be a good
idea to get that knight off the board
he's also got a little bit less time so
we kind of called it you know
all of these games are a lot closer than
they may appear on paper
no 100 i mean we've we've had
a lot of surprises in in a lot of good
ways where every i mean
mr beast last time and we had uh
now we've got i mean this is a this is a
position where objectively if you forgot
who the players are i mean white white
has a lot of potential here to be much
better this d5 square is going to be a
problem for the rest of the game
and it's also almost an easier position
for myth to play because
this bishop is bad this square is weak
like black has more long-term problems
that would take a lot of experience to
outmaneuver
vice position is kind of just easier to
play here right now
it absolutely is you could bring the
rooks in you could prepare to position
the knight on d5 i agree
and that is being reflected in the time
consumption sardoche
not concerning yet but he takes two more
minutes you know
then things start getting a little bit
dicey for him
and if i were him i would put a rook on
c8 i would try to
create some threats do something tricky
maybe target that c4 pawn
that moved to the side of the board
knight a5 is still interesting but it's
not a move that's easy to see danny if
you're not
very familiar with this position as you
were talking about yep
you know and it's already lost some of
its punch it was it obviously would have
won the pawn earlier
when the queen had nowhere to go now if
you play 95 the queen can even make the
most natural move for a player of a lot
of levels queen a4
and black is in trouble so this will be
a good test can myth maintain i was just
going to say can he maintain the time
advantage and just
and just play quick logical moves this
isn't this isn't a totally bad move but
it's
it's definitely overly aggressive and if
sardosh sees knight g4
oh man suddenly the dark squares are
backfiring for white so
um again this is one of those signs we
talk about where
players learn over time like once you
have an advantage sometimes the simplest
moves are how you build on that strength
i keep using that term
you're building your pieces behind your
pawns for their potential rather than
kind of lashing out for one move threats
and and um anyway
still totally anybody's game and i'm
just nervous now about what could happen
on the dark squares for myth
likewise and another way to think about
why f4 is
not such a good move is because well
first of all you push upon in front of
your king not directly in front of your
king but in that general vicinity
which weakens the diagonal and also if
you take a look at that bishop on e3
you've got to be super careful about it
because it's lost its defender now it's
undefended
which means that if uh sardocia attacks
it
that's another threat that myth has to
worry about sardosh could now take
either with the knight to threaten the
d3 bishop or he could take with a rook
to threaten the bishop i was just
talking about i would probably take
with the knight or even the pawn in
order to secure that d4 square in the
center
yeah agreed on takes here
you know also knight takes hits this
bishop and has a discovery maybe on the
next move which a discovery is when you
move a piece
to unleash an attack of another piece
behind it so
yeah okay he takes with the rook this is
kind of the most straightforward you
feel like
you got to deliver a punch move because
it immediately creates an attack
but knight takes actually had it's more
like more like putting gunpowder in the
gun right knight takes was actually a
little more powerful
um and because of the discovery tactic
that we talked about okay but
either way these guys are playing really
really good chess this is very close
still anybody's game yeah now there's
there's a really awesome of rook takes
bishops now myth has defended it
but because he's weak in that diagonal
by pushing his f
on uh starters would take the bishop and
play queen to b6 but that's a super
advanced tactic danny
and knight g4 is also really good and
here we see myth starting to pay the
price
for that weakening move and that is what
could end up
really hurting him he's got to be super
careful and the weakening move we're
talking about is that move just a few
moments ago f4 if you're just tuning in
or
kind of a reminder of the big picture
because if this bishop moves to the
wrong square just to show i mean moves
like this come in
and the game is is is almost over
because black is going to grab the dark
squares
and all kinds of dangerous things are
going to happen to the white king so
this is a very very scary proposition
here
okay knight d5 what excellent wow
that is the only move actually that is
the only good way that he finds it
that was huge and it also shows the
recognition
that this knight left the square behind
so it's it's the best defense is a good
offense right he defends the bishop and
attacks the queen
oh man and he's also of two minutes on
the clock this is gonna come down to the
wire
below five minutes now for sardo she
spent more than half his time and we
know what happens when these players
they dip it to two minutes one minute
danny they're not as
experienced in bullet chest one minute
chess so they start to panic and that is
a
very very important consideration two
whole minutes up on the clock
myth is looking good here yeah and if
this queen moves to the wrong square
smith could save his dark square bishop
and attack the rook and suddenly you
just you look at snapshot and it feels
like all white's pieces are on really
good squares if he owns the e-file
but yeah this is a critical moment for
sardosh and i think he's gonna
i think he's gonna spend on the whole
other minute maybe thinking about it i
mean this is this is a tough position
and you can see how zoned in he is
let's take a listen into mitch he's
talking to us about his ideas
he's around the map we're on the board
we place this queen up to pressure my
rook
it's actually a really good move
actually not if he plays the right
response
yeah but it's a strong idea by sardosh
for sure right at least
but like this move doesn't really do
anything because
at the end of the day like i just take
his queen
well this isn't really that big of a
deal
matter of fact it's actually he just
opened up
this rook take for me oh my god he
opened up this pawn for me
this was a misplay by him i think oh my
lands
i love his thought process i've been
watching him solve puzzles and
oh well i guess he could go for a knife
oh no he could go for my knight
maybe that's not what i'm looking at
maybe that's something i'm not looking
at
is
yeah that might be the kicker that he's
actually going for no
he'll drop the bishop if he moves
tonight
yourself
i want to sing like elsa ah so
wait don't move the bishop either
because you'll drop the rook
gonna do it so he's threatening two
pieces at once right now
three pieces actually no he's starting
to see ghosts
actually not threatening anything i
think my best move is
i wonder why he gave up on queen seven
because he said it yeah
he thought the knight was hanging with
that pawn on c4 is defending directly
defending the knight
we like that he's taking his time though
because maybe he'll come back to finding
he only has two threatens
all here so maybe if i go knight b6
it'll like divert his attention here and
i have two takes here
for his two so he takes i take take take
or if he doesn't do anything around that
and he like plays around here
then i get his knight as well
let's do that let's see how that plays
out maybe that's not the right thing but
it does drop the piece of stardust
reacts real quick he takes that knight
that's what there's
so the reason it's losing everybody
it was right about the fact that he has
the pieces defending but exactly he
thought that the knight was crucial
defending the bishop
and sardosh doesn't have to be asked
twice oh man
yeah but sardosh was in a bit of an
inaccurate move though
he allows smith to take the rope cerdo
should have taken the knight first
yeah yeah no you're right he should have
taken it okay so actually
see if myth follows through on the idea
of why the knight moved there
the thing is no you go ahead
i was just going to say quickly that
that the in the grand scheme of things
sardosh played the right move because he
can
slide his queen over to c5 fair discover
check but i think
judging by his facial reaction he
actually missed the fact that the rook
was hanging
we'll see right yeah if he finds queen
c5 everyone
this this was actually exactly this rook
is so irrelevant to the position
you're threatening some of the most
famous baiting nets in the world right
venus fly traps and dart and back rank
mates are on the agenda so
if he sees queen c5 uh
just really on track for uh for a park
champs victory i think
that's a really strong move um he's
nervous
he's nervous yep and he's only got three
minutes
until he's grabbing his head and
i think he missed knight take say that
unsettled him
will he gather himself together here
d4 is also not a bad move it shows he
recognized the dark squares but not
winning like queen c5 would have been
right now myth has to take that pawn on
d7 his queen queen is under attack
he's got to play aggressively here see
that the pawn on b7 is hanging
all right let's listen and see if myth
is on track with that idea
and i could get out of it by taking pawn
you go
i could
like trust himself it's definitely an
option
overthinking it like this is taken
i can't move here i can't move here i
can't move anywhere here
can't move here i can't move here
i think the uh i think yeah so that
forces me to go for this pawn i'm pretty
sure
[ __ ] all right i take pawn
brilliant i think that's a good move
even like that's my only move there
to get my queen out of danger i feel
like
i'm gonna hope he's gotta move into
position to attack
queen d2 will be very strong here yeah
let's come back to this
show his knights are going to be like
objectively black is still winning queen
d2 is
super strong i think even putting the
queen on c5 is still super problematic
but this was an aggressive move that
myth needed to play because if sardosh
doesn't convert
bc8 b8 in fact ic2
is exactly the kind of mistake you can
make you could trade and then trade
still have ideas of queen coming in
right this is like but this is anyone's
game make no mistake
the eval bar is not important here time
scramble this is what we signed up for
now myth has to take that knight and
then take sardocia's rook otherwise
he's going to lose one of these syrups
this is a fork
yeah a fork is when a knight or pawn
attacks two pieces at once you can also
call it a double attack
but uh this move is is crucial because
it it's going to force myth to have to
stay aggressive and what i was going to
compliment earlier daniel than i
we were listening in but one thing i
i've noticed he does is partly because
he solves so much puzzles
if does a great job the moment someone
plays a move his first instinct unlike a
lot of people is he always looks for
their threat
like you can hear it in his thought
process he talks about the rook right
even if he doesn't see right away that
you know the rook is protected or the
knight had protection of c4 pawn
his mindset is very prophylactic he's
always looking for it and i think as he
learns different concepts dania and gets
better
it's going to make him a very good
player i really believe that
no he's got that correct logic in place
and that just that doesn't come easy and
unfortunately blunders that rope
i think he got attracted danny by that
bishop but the thing is the bishop isn't
hanging it's defended by the queen
and takes the correct rook and the look
at the queen is defending both the
knight and the bishop
white is down a piece now his initiative
fizzling out but
what an effort in the middle game here
by by myth but sardoche
staying strong in the critical moments
and speeding up when he had to
hess talks about this a lot right
retreating moves are just the ones you
miss a lot especially in blitz and this
is
i think you're 100 right that's exactly
what he missed with queen d7
just literally literary literary and i
need to go back to the school for kids
who don't read good
i cannot be literally yet anyway queen
d7 just missed that this was on the
agenda and now he's
gonna pay the price i think i think
andreas will win this one with two
minutes on the clock
yeah and you can just tell i think he's
he's still nervous
but i think he senses that the game is
turned around and now the clock
not myths friend either he's got now
down to a minute
unfortunately for white there's no
checks against black skin everything is
protected so
just down a piece now white's king is
the one on the chopping block
yeah i see chad saying and agree he's
definitely better than 4.95 the moment
some of these things start coming
together
myth is gonna make i think bigger leaps
than than people will
expect because he's doing so many things
right but
um he's kind of almost too defensive
minded in some ways
yeah i mean he you know it's easy for us
to say you got to trust yourself
everybody does that to a degree but um
he really as you said
danny you really does zero in on the
right things almost immediately and that
is just not
something that anyone takes for granted
that's that's some talent right there
great and it's funny there's an outside
chance that something weird happens here
if sardosh takes this knight with the
bishop
and this check comes in and if black
wonders something like
king h7 oh wait i forgot the knight was
even attacking the mission never mind
even this doesn't work because i was
going to go for some fancy thing like
this and highlight
exactly like the eval bar said it's made
but the bishop is even hanging so
super tough but anyway there are some
maybe outside chances there's only a
minute for sardosh too so this is
oh he did take he took with the bishop
it takes if myth gives check and he
moves the king instead of blocking with
the bishop
we could have a wild ending like i just
predicted
yeah if myth sees that lobster pincer
theme
um and i think myth is going to give the
check on c8 that's really the only thing
he can do here
unfortunately i'm worried that he's just
panicking and the
chance is vanishingly small but
nonetheless are dosh
stepping up in the critical moment here
gotta give him some credit and b4 by
myth that's a really interesting movie
he's distracting the queen
from its defense of the bishop oh my
gosh this
okay just to show real quick before we
listen in if the queen takes and this
check happens
now there's no bishop d8 black would
still be winning but now you have to see
this retreating move
otherwise g6 and you get mated on f8 so
let's listen into myth and see what
happens here but this this could still
be a wild finish
below a minute now actually good
um so this gives me what
this gives me free the discover check is
gonna be devastating
things aren't as bad as they used to be
oh maybe i lied
[Laughter]
yep what am i oh wow that's track
c5
i don't see five right oh we don't block
a pawn
move to a white checkmate there's still
that one checkmate okay
regardless oh it all goes downhill dude
it goes south so fast
oh no
[Music]
good game my guy
wow what an intense game danny that was
crazy
good guess what they got another one
fifth that was tough lasting in defeat
that was a lot closer i think than than
people i mean that almost had if he
doesn't play queen d4
and and sardoche doesn't check on the
next move
this idea of f6 setting up the checkmate
was what we had been looking at for a
while
that was that was super wild and i
thought we might have a fall out of your
chair
uh moment luckily i have a chair with
back support now we've been upgrading
the office a little that i feel
a lot better that was
such a smooth transition danny i have no
words but they've got a second game
and uh myth has just put everyone on
notice that he is
he is here to play and he is going to
deal some blows and he almost did in
this game
i mean uh lundwig said mr beast has got
the you know consolation
bracket victory written all over i think
myth too because we know he's he's
continuing to grind and get better
throughout the whole event
these games are are really showing uh a
different player than one that
we saw first learning the game on his
streams a few weeks ago so
all right we're gonna take a break we
have our last game of the day don't go
anywhere it's pogchamps three presented
by grip
six final game of the day when we return
hang it man dude the time was ticking i
was under pressure
oh no i just needed to use my eyeballs
wait but wasn't i wait
no wait no i couldn't have no i couldn't
have
maybe like okay wait hold up maybe i
could have done it
let's see where i could have done it
if i would have moved on now
now and gone for this no no i don't have
this i think
i don't think i have this ever because i
move pawn he takes and then
this just has a slot so even if i go
here
i never get that
i could get the check but i don't think
i ever get the mate here
does that make sense yeah i don't think
i ever get the mate
check first move on palm
check first check first then move on
oh true
[Music]
check move pawn it's over
[Music]
yeah dude that's above my pay grade i'm
not gonna lie
there's a gnat as well inside of here
that's kind of bothering driving me
crazy
hard to spot yeah for sure
gg
dang
especially like i was under pressure as
well like i was running out of time at
this moment so i was just like dude
yeah this this this was actually the
play
and then he goes here i go here
and then wait doesn't he just cover with
pawn
oh yeah chad he just covers the pawn
and then and then what
then you move queen to f8
okay and then he does what after this
mate and one oh because i go here
yeah he does like this or so he does
whatever he does here i win
oh dude yeah i didn't see that that's
like a that's like a checkmate in three
i hold up
let's go here do this one
two
three
he has no counter to this
he can't kill my pawn in any way can't
get my
i guess he could do this but then
yeah he could just do that and then it's
yeah then i can't do that but then i
would have to wait but then i would my
move instead of doing that would be this
and then he would go i don't know
he could go he would do well then he
would take this and then that would no
this pla i don't think this plan would
work
but we are in a better position to win
the game though i think if i'm like this
for sure
yeah wait no he does that i still could
win off of that
i see yeah we could have won
damn well
the more you know
bang game over a little pawn that could
we got next game maybe we could uh take
it off some uh emote only for a little
bit
uh let the chess chatters flow in
sorry for disappointing you guys i bet
that was really difficult for a lot of
people to look at
but that's like that's a hard thing to
do you would block queen with bush
bishop to prevent check oh oh wait
actually yeah wait no yeah we're
completely missing this
in an ideal world i do this
he just does that
i lost my queen
easy
blood is analyzing your game that's very
nice of him
hope he's enjoying analyzing my game why
don't you look at an analysis uh you did
not have a force mate
and we all deliver on our promises
around here
pog champs three presented by grip six
look at mr beast coming through in the
clutch he didn't waste any time
donating the ten grand plus apparently
two hundred dollars i don't maybe that's
the
price of admission or something i don't
know but ten thousand dollars
plus 200 to a charity that is
unconfirmed but this just went down on
twitter
um and that was because he bet ludwig
that he would donate 10k
so it's pretty bleep and awesome that
that just happened danya
damn girl that is that is amazing that
is a lot of zeros
and that was a great match too so uh all
around
awesome stuff going on yeah
that is a big number i can't wait to see
what else happens uh throughout this
whole next couple weeks
um and to remind everybody what we're
doing over these next couple weeks we're
also raising money for charity
uh we still got a lot of time to reach
our goal of a hundred thousand dollars
remember
every dollar you donate is matched by
chess.com
the the company itself in addition to
the hundred thousand dollar prize for
the players we are putting a hundred
thousand dollars more toward charities
that are chosen by our players and uh
it's gonna be split up
based on the prizes they win so whatever
whatever you might be interested in
doing we do appreciate it we see some
incredible charities st
jude's chose by mr beast right there uh
just because we were talking about him
but amazing charity shows and as i said
some of these are super
super intimate and near and dear to
these people's uh these people's hearts
these these celebrities arts here and
uh and so if any of them ring a bell for
you uh we we saw rayne talk about his uh
charity he has with his wife
support uh girls education and all kinds
of amazing things in haiti
um yesterday so anyway consider it we do
appreciate use the command charity
command donate and chat if you want to
learn more info
all right rocking and rolling into our
last game
we'd be strolling oh my god danny stop
rhyming people are watching you
wow that was import i'm impressed
i mean if only we had logic here to
evaluate that i know
um we throw down some rhymes from time
to time
um no we don't actually we only talk yes
pretty much
i'm kidding um anyway uh this is gonna
be a lot of fun
what you said and i saw chat talking
about it on chess tv
uh exploration time was talking about
how impressive myth was there we saw him
at the break
taking time to actually look at that
mate pattern that i showed right with
the f6 queen f8 so he's really putting
in the time after his games to learn and
get better
and now he's got a grub to deal with
a grub named after henry grubb and uh
sometimes danny i feel like the name of
the opening sort of
implies whether it's good or bad and uh
let me just say that the grub is
not on an objective level a good opening
and henry graub is not a bad player grub
also means like a
coffin in in russian so it kind of
represents the kind of opening this is
but he's already in a good position
because
mitt's last move was not very accurate
yeah his first move was good for the
record everyone when when someone part
of the reason the grab isn't good if we
just want to talk principles is
because it's not a move that attacks the
center so principally
principally i am i am all over the map
today with my words i apologize
uh the principles of grabbing the center
come back and you should play e5 or d5
so e5 was good but then this move allows
the knight to get kicked around
and uh oh it's already it's already even
worse he's losing the knight
and that's the thing with these openings
right they're bad from an objective
standpoint but they can be
great at surprise weapons and they can
contain all these vicious traps now a
myth
he's got to get it together and he's got
to give that knight up danny for as much
as he can that means taking the pawn on
f2 biting the bullet
and doing as much damage as you can
let's go
listen into what myth is talking about
because he is considering that i believe
this is bad um
okay well he's going to get two pawns
this way listen man if i'm losing
a d4 now knight e3 is
actually a really cool move 93 is
actually a super strong move and
black would be winning if i'm losing i'm
getting two pawns out of it
that's really hard that you might take
on f2 you understand me
[Music]
if i'm losing i'm getting two pawns out
of that bad boy
oh no oh checking he wants to check oh
he goes for a check
yeah but now c3 that puts another piece
on fire
now he's in big trouble
all right who do i not want to
hope lose doesn't forget his queen's
hanging
yeah a lot of stuff is hanging three
pieces to be exact
actually i don't think he's gonna take
anything he jinxed him oh my lands
oh no oh
abort [ __ ] gotta just
abort [ __ ] boys ship
wow oh man you know that you know that
it was kevin's influence he's got the
famous video where he drew magnus
carlson with the grub kevin bourdain if
you don't know
is a good friend i'm teasing he's kind
of the face of chess.com to the french
chess community and he does an awesome
job for us
here at this company but he is
responsible for this rob that
unfortunately
just torched myth and this this whole
idea is how dangerous the grop can be
although sardoche did make a huge
mistake here with d4 if myth had seen 93
everyone
that would have blocked the queen and
given a discovered attack to the bishop
here
um again we talk about discoveries is
where you move a piece and you don't
even attack with that piece you attack
with a piece behind it
um that was his chance he missed it and
unfortunately
actually blundered his queen along the
way oh that hurts oh
man yeah that's so frustrating and you
know
they all went they went all aboardy the
ship
the grab ship including sirdosh
i mean i'm on a roll today it's
unequivocal you are spitting hot fire
your rhymes are tight on that mic um
dang right yeah and this is just a queen
down full queen down
yeah this is um unfortunately
unfortunate
myth and um i know he's got good
coaching he's working with maurice
ashley and others uh but
uh anyway
like you said that's the danger of these
openings go ahead
and that's that's what chess is you know
it's it's one of those things where
one little thing is wrong for you and
you've got so much
to take care of and so much to watch
that unless you're super experienced
getting out of these situations and not
blundering more pieces is
one of the hardest skills in chess
because you're so disconcerted
sardo's not playing this great but i
mean he's a queen up basically anything
wins
yeah it's funny because the final score
is again not going to be indicative of
how close this match was that first game
was moves from going the other way and
seconds they were both under mutual time
pressure
this game here it's not to take anything
away from sardosh it's good coaching
from kevin bourdieu and it's an opening
he knows well but
but he's not necessarily playing the
most accurate moves he actually even
even made a big mistake earlier as we've
highlighted a couple times but
but um you know but he's
still going to get the w here because
this is just almost an impossible
position for black to come back in
yeah the smooth bishop h3 that he played
might strike people's weird but he's
going to push that g
pawn up i think he can also take the
pawn on e5 but i think the idea was to
open that bishop up by pushing the grub
pawn up
instead he decides to take on the take
on e5 literally anything is winning here
but ultimately i think that he's
probably going to try to mate black down
the h file he's going to play g5 and
bring the queen up to h5
[Music]
agreed tail population us
that was a good one never heard that one
before pushing the
push in the uh the awkward envelope
over to you now dude that is an envelope
i'm
very familiar with and bishop h boyd
tries to put that bishop in front of the
rook
but here g4 did you fight would be very
very strong opening up that file giving
up
sacrificing the groupon but i think he's
emotionally attached to to the grab pawn
yeah it's upon it's a pawn you
fall in love with right you start
pushing g4 and you never go back
um yeah brings tears to my eyes
i thought pawn is behind many
experiences that i had in my life
i've even got a g4 emote on my own
twitch channel super active
channel twitch.tv slash daniel wrench
definitely worth a follow i stream all
the time
uh yeah yeah you're the best streamer in
history
in the history of streamers best um
the uh all right queen b3 also not a bad
move
i mean sardosh as you said can play
almost anything here
um
yeah and as do they say on twitch
well saj or white people sad
sad badge but there's saj but
i usually am not saj i'm more mad i'm
gonna introduce another word to
the twitch sphere i thought it was sage
sage no but it comes from sad right so
it's gotta be sash but i'm gonna
introduce the word madge
which just means um not
sad but mad but on twitch
okay i didn't even know right and um
got a lot to learn my contribution to
society
actually i stole this from good friend
who
coined this word we don't want to
revisit some of the things i had to
learn in pog champs too
appropriate and one of the most viral
clips i learned recently i'm not even
going to talk about it i don't want to
talk about it
you don't want to talk about it well i'm
pretty mad that you don't want to talk
about it and
andrea's capturing another night oh now
everything is falling
yeah this is just tough though i mean
honestly as we said
and we were kind of foreshadowing i had
the fear had this feeling when he played
bishop before check that the
the attack he would remember is the most
recent one right that's a very easy
mistake to make as a chess player when
you make a move and someone
attacks a piece you're mainly focused on
that piece forgetting that
you already kind of got yourself in a
world of trouble earlier
and so once this queen was lost um
as you said it's uh
all over red rover some myth right over
and uh and one of the things that we
noticed about
stronger players is typically a lot of
players at this level
and again it's no shame but this is why
it's it's you know it's a learning
experience but a lot of times from zero
to 14 even 1500
you know strength can vary wildly
blunders can be made all over the place
but i think the difference between the
stronger players in the event is
when they get a winning position they're
very unlikely to blow it right and you
see some of them play with the
confidence of ludwig today the pre-move
to checkmate right i mean it was awesome
and i think sardoce is going to be one
of those guys where if you're going to
get them
you know you can't you can't go down
this kind of material
yeah i mean definitely set the gold
standard with uh with that technique but
the problem is yeah you're up a queen up
a piece and it really the sad thing is
it doesn't
matter even the specific moves you make
um as long as you defend against the
threats
uh because you know because there's just
too much extra stuff and you're
absolutely right i think you hit the
nail on the head danny
where it it's not that you know sardosi
doesn't make mistakes it's all about the
consistency though
he doesn't blunder too much and even if
he's not playing great
he's not going to shoot himself in the
foot too many times
yep make this is playing quickly
uh or he's trying to speed up now
because he's down down to four minutes
um
instantly broke back to c8 now the grab
pawn
is moved to unleash yet another
discovered attack apparently we're doing
basic tactical themes here today
unleashing an attack behind it
yep there it goes 10 moves after i
thought it would be played but
he doesn't i'm afraid myth might take
that pawn see that's another thing
where you tunnel vision the thing that's
hanging but
that's what where i've been impressed by
myth and well
of course i have to jinx him as always
yeah but he is his logic is impressive
that doesn't take anything away from him
yep oh man
well he's uh we're going to have
interviews with the players obviously so
don't go anywhere the day is not over
yet we will check in with them and again
the uh the pogchamps event is young and
still a lot a lot of chess to be seen
from these guys
let's tune in with myth here and get his
final thoughts as this game comes to a
close
can help me i need help listen if there
are any chess.com viewers
send help send help i'm down
bad i don't know if they have my audio
on but look at my lips
i'm down horrendous i am down
bad send backup send the cia
send the fbi send the men in black
i don't send somebody
oh no oh
death is beth is among us boys
the si the ship is sinking
all has failed us this game
things aren't looking too hot
all right woman woman and uh woman and
children first
get in the like get in the wraps
get in the wraps take refuge
yeah this is a fitting a fitting uh
way of describing the situation oh
[Music]
not over nice yeah i think stardust is
enough pieces here
that was fun
again the final scoreboard and the way
that game went i mean
some of the games can be misleading like
that not not to say against hardocious
and a super strong player but it
definitely was kind of off the rails in
an unfair way
for myth early and there was there was
no slowing down the uh
the train there right no for sure
sardocis his grinding is coming through
he's consistent he's solid he's
he's a a serious player and uh myth uh
myth did the very best that he could and
that first game was super competitive
danny
uh he's going to uh he's going to fire
some bullets in this tournament for sure
all right well there may be no slowing
down sardosh but there's also no slowing
down grip six
our official presenting sponsor uh
reminder
you you gotta go to grip6.com right now
you can also go to go.just.com
script6 but either way you're going to
use the pogchamps 20 promotion code to
get 20
off i highly recommend the socks i've
had no shame about it
people don't believe me i tweeted
earlier before the match started that
uh that i was wearing the socks um but
again
they're a belt company first the belts
are awesome no flap
no bulk right there the belt is comfy
head over to grip6.com
you'll get a chance to win that custom
chest set don't go anywhere we have
interviews
we'll be right back
you will be surprised other times you
surprise your opponent
but overall um i think
for instance here i know this is this is
already like it's not
pleasant but where would you move the
night
what other squares do you have for the
night
um d5
or better square for the knight down
before
d5 is safe e4
is fine um
or um g4
yes so you have g4 e4 d5
let's compare these two because those
seem to be
the most natural when it comes to going
toward the center you place your knight
immediately in the center so that would
make sense that we are going to one of
these squares but
one is a lot better than the other
um if you have your knight here and i
want you to visualize it yeah because
night jumps are those tricky ones and we
can still
always practice if the knight is on e4
can you find a move for
white that would make sure that that
knight
is attacked and can not jump to any
square without being captured
we want to trap the knight on e4
so what what would be white's move yes
yeah i want you to picture the the night
uh your night on e4 and i'd like you to
find a move for why that would trap it
the night
because it looks like a good spot but
there's a move a very annoying one by
white
that would attack it and capture it
i don't think the night is safe on any
square
after going there
but you're saying what what is the
attack it would it be just
yeah pawn that's that's the solution but
you
you were immediately understanding that
oh
like from here it can cannot go to any
of these squares
so this is something to take into
account when you choose where to place
your pieces
is that once it's there does it have
where to go
and in this case this knight has no
jumps
it has no moves so as active as it looks
there there will be games where the
knight is very well placed there
but that's why everything has to has to
be observed
in the context of the rest of the pieces
that knight could be a beast in another
game and in this game it's a very clumsy
piece
because it has nowhere to jump to okay
so you are right d3
attacks the knight and wherever the
knight goes it's trapped
yeah okay yeah what about knight to d5
is it the same situation or do you have
moves from d5 for the knight
if in case it's attack because white
could attack it right
right
here
um yeah there are more places for it to
go
so it means that our knight is not in
trouble
on d5 right yeah amazing
so for next time even if the position is
unpleasant because in this case
normally your knight is not chased away
just try to
try to see what are some of the better
alternatives because
even if it's not denied but any other
piece if you have already developed a
piece
try not to put it back to the initial
square
because then it's then it's something
that didn't actually do anything
yeah so it took us one move to get the
knight out to
six and another move to go back which
means that you spent two moves
and the knight is on the initial square
that's why these moves
um as much as we can we try to avoid
them
because it loses remember when i was
trying to explain to you what is
time in chess and not on the clock but
time in the position
yeah this is time because it was two
moves oh yeah
a temple yes it was two moves to move
the knight back and forth
and it's on the same square so you're
gonna need a third move
to move it again excellent
excellent i like i appreciate you
helping me go through
the the possibility of if a blunder hat
like this happens again because that's
yeah that's the type of training i
hadn't even
like i feel like a lot of times i look
at my games and i i
figure out what would have been the best
move
instead of the blunder but that's like
next level to think about what's the
next move
after you've made a blunder yes it's
important that
just because this move i'm sure that in
this moment you sense that oh something
is not
quite right it's not exactly our setup
but even if it happens to you
it's not the end of the world so there's
always there's always a way to put up
more resistance you should always try to
find the strongest response even when
the position is
not the coolest not the nicest
it's this is far from being decisive
it's just
an unpleasant move and yes he has even
if you have the knight here he would
have these tricks that he pushes the
pawn
and the rook is attacked so it's not
easy to counter these kind of surprise
attacks
it comes out of the blue it's literally
move five and you're already being
attacked by all of these pieces the pawn
and the bishop
so um i just need you to to
to understand this part too yes what you
said that even though
there will be occasions when your
opponent surprises you sometimes
in the opening sometimes in the middle
game it's also possible that you miss an
idea in the middle game at a later stage
so
it's not necessarily an opening
preparation thing it's more about just
the mentality that what i told you about
okay moves
it's also okay to miss ideas it's also
okay to miss moves so
i just need you to be like super chill
about oh i missed it
okay my bad but next page blank page
this is the situation how do i put up
the most resistance possible
got it okay
yeah and well the way we are learning
about these for instance these night
jumps to compare them
it's not only for this exact position i
just want you to
to use this kind of thinking overall
in general in your games because you may
not have this position in your next
matches
but you could have a similar situation
where it's a choice of
where do i place the knight do i want to
go back or will i try to move it to a
more active square especially if it's
the center
and what's the difference between e4 and
d5 where is the knight
safe we want to keep our pieces safe d5
excellent excellent job i think i was
being told that we were on the
the main broadcast so hello to everybody
these like these uh these uh put you on
blast in front of a hundred thousand
people without warning
we got to be on our best behavior at all
times yeah of course it's t5
you've just spotted 95 so i think we
were in the right moment
we can be talking about about series in
the meantime and there for those five
minutes something instructive
you're doing an amazing job michelle and
we are here to learn from this game
because it wasn't an easy one and after
e6 again
let's say you already had the knight
there let's say this is bad but
i want you to again put up the most
resistance possible what's the main
threat of your opponent okay so main
thread is bishop takes on h8
so my thought now that this has happened
a a better move could have been f6
to get one possible pawn out of the way
of this annoying pawn on the sixth
rank and also block um
the bishop excellent blocks the diagonal
saves the rook and stuff actually i
believe was like you should have gone
f6 and i was like oh yeah
i didn't hear this part when he told you
but i i
i was switching back and forth because i
was like on your channel i can hear your
thought process i was mainly watching
your stream
don't tell the show i'm going to be on
the show tomorrow and such but like oh
can't wait to see
you see it from your perspective i think
i'll be on
on thursday too when you are playing
no no no that's no pressure because it's
the same
it's the same tournament and i would be
watching regardless whether i'm casting
or not i'm watching
so you did very well yesterday but yes
f6
that saves the rook and then this pawn
alone is not that big of a deal
what's your next move if your opponent
doesn't touch the spawn if that pawn
stays there what do you do
let's say i move here
and we are back here pogchamps3 we're
now joined by both of our players
we've got myth we've got andreas on
audio thanks for being with us again
guys
hello hi everyone
yeah yeah myth let me let me start with
you we got we got the chessboard up what
was a critical position
in the in in the first game which was a
super intense game you both got under
time pressure
danya and i were super nervous over here
we had no idea what was going to happen
take us through your thought process
though because when the queen went to a5
i was singing your praises myth that a
lot of times in your games you
immediately are looking at your
opponent's threats first which a lot of
people don't do that they do the
opposite
but then after that you did see that you
could take b7
but kind of got away from it and
dismissed it eventually eventually went
with a different move like
what why did you end up not taking the
b7 pawn when you first saw it
hold on we've lost we've lost your audio
myth one second
oh sorry all right you're sorry yeah
yeah honestly
i have no idea
it happened it's okay it happens that
way sometimes yeah
i dish it out to inexperience and just
second guessing myself the pressure of
being
you know in the tournament setting in
the tournament event
and uh yeah i think that's all that's
all i really chop it down to
i don't think there's any other excuse
you know inexperience
and and and uh second guessing myself
not being confident in the move that i
think is right
when i think it's right you know as the
first game was
so intense like i was i actually didn't
even see the rook
i was so so stressed and panicked when
when you played so
aggressive at first and i focused on my
plan and
i felt like i could defend if you would
commit to my
my king and i was like okay well i will
focus on my things
and i will let him do stuff i i hope it
works but
finally it works but i i already think
suku you are really close like
maybe some some 10 hours of training to
to beat me on the first game for sure
but the second game sadly you had no
preparation for this grub and
it was it was a bit harder i guess
before we even talk about the grav in
this first game uh
donny and i were we're on the edge of
our seat right here
there was there was almost a potential
tactic with queen c8
f6 donna you want you want to take us
through that
yeah so and and myth i was impressed
with the fact that you were analyzing
this afterwards so this check on c8
could follow
and then uh andreas maybe you saw that
then the king
runs to h7 which is not the only move
but then you play f6 check
and uh black can take the bishop and
that's the saving grace because if black
goes g6
then the queen slides over to f8 and
that's a lobster pincer
so you know this was close until the
very end and
andres you played very well in the final
stage of the game to sort of make sure
that your king was safe but
it was intense as well we had no we had
no time actually we were both at two
minutes or one and
it was so stressful to actually find the
good move and
not blunder in this situation
like wow damn at that point in the game
i remember
even like at this very phase i was
looking at the time and i was like oh
man 30 seconds left i just gotta move
something
and i don't have time to like i don't
think i was
um i don't think i'm i was like good
enough i literally told myself like i'm
not good enough to to come up or think
about the right thing at the right time
i just need to move so i don't
just lose time at the time we had one
minute left and i just
i just thought about my my code with
swift tough then
he told me just move the pc then it will
go well so
well speaking of your coach sardosh
before we move on from that
obviously uh mr blitzstream himself
kevin bourdee gets credit for the grub
this is uh yeah it worked out here
obviously man crazy
he just played against magnus carson
himself with maybe
600 you know under him and he actually
beat him with a grub so
i guess this is some some fun to play
and actually i
i learned chess with that opening so
it forced me to play really tactic
already
mostly with tactics so i can't really
just position my pieces and win
i need to find a way to crush my
opponent so
this is how i learn chess this is why i
struggle so much with close position and
this is why i force myself to play
london system to actually grind
and learn lunches yeah
i think that's not a bad idea to
actually play grub to launches
you might be the first but that's that's
really cool
i guess if it's good enough for magnus
it's good enough for myth so maybe
you're in good company with the world
champion the grub is
the grub is hard to handle um but
you know seriously man i know you said
yourself chalk it up to inexperience but
but i mean that in a good way that there
were a lot of things we listened in on
you a lot
and there were a lot of times your
thought process was like totally
on point and i just want to say that
because there were there were moments
where
and that game came down to the wire
where we were we were singing your
praises
and i know that you know where this
event is heading i just uh every every
time we we
watch you stream here and play chess
it's you're just getting better every
time man so
just want to say that thank you liz man
paul champs four
and our next match i have a few days so
i'm gonna i'm gonna you know nose to the
grindstone and hopefully you know i
could pull off a few dubs against nico
but then you know it from here and until
then i like chess as a game
i really want to stick to it and uh
maybe maybe i'll see you guys next year
you know
yeah but it's a lot absolutely
the way you're doing right now for sure
great games guys thank you
thanks a lot guys
all right well um you heard it
everyone's already talking about
pogchamps four i mean
first of all it may not be next year
maybe maybe it'll be this year but i
will say that
there's been so much positivity from
this especially this particular group
and
um i know a lot of them off stream have
been talking that way
um and uh and on stream as well so
sardoche takes it continues to impress
and that was our final score
of today but let's preview tomorrow
speaking of someone who's already been
talking about pogchamps four pokemane
has been obsessed with chess she'll be
back against xqc but to kick things off
we have rubius and negron you nico and
benji fishy omg's are snaps dania which
match are you most looking forward to
tomorrow
well i've i've got to go with xqc
against pokemon the others are going to
be super interesting too
but i'm so excited to see how
much xqc has improved and i've heard
about pokemans grinding as well so danny
that's going to be a marquee matchup
and that's i'm going to have my my eyes
glued to the screen
no agreed and you know obviously xuc got
the job done against rubius with the 2-0
victory
but those games were super close right i
mean anyone who watched yesterday
uh if you didn't shame on you check out
the vaude but uh rubius xuc rubius even
had a mate one it could have gone anyway
so i i think pokey and and xqc are going
to have a crazy match
i'm with you that that's the one that's
uh hard to turn away from of course all
the others look crazy too
nico and benji fishy and rubios and
negroni so
speaking of crazy man it's been a wild
day how you feeling
wow four hours three and a half hours
have gone by and a flash we've got
so many ups and downs and i have to
second what you said earlier danny just
amazing high quality performances all
across the board
whether by the favorites or by um
first time players i think everybody
just put their hearts out on the line
today and
produced some amazing chess yeah and i
know we keep talking about it
but it has been something that i think
was partly inspired by the queen's
gambit i was teasing
jimmy mr beast about it but there's a
there was something about
the the the vibe of coming to this event
that it wasn't just that people were
inspired to play chess i think i think
the series it was like people were
inspired to learn and get better and
we've seen that and we've seen so many
people
just diving into lessons and coaching
and it's been a ton of fun so it makes
me think that
where we're going from now to the end of
this event over the next couple weeks
we're going to see everyone continue to
get better maybe ludwig's right maybe
that consolation bracket will just be
nuts right regardless of who's in it in
terms of how good they've gotten
so um anyway amazing stuff want to give
one last shout out to
all of our subscribers there's been a
ton of you today and tons of people also
throwing in
some cash toward our charity goals which
are big we're going to continue to get
there
we really appreciate your support and we
hope you can see
continue seeing that being driven up to
the team the crew
working hard all of our mods hardly
working
working
hard no they're all working hard um to
my partner
well to my partner as well so you know
who's gonna is gonna be the first to say
uh mean things about
the other that's the question no one's
gonna say mean things i mean
um thanks thanks to everybody that was a
lot of fun danny
it was a lot of fun thanks to everyone
for tuning in and we will see you
tomorrow
for another day of pogchamps three
presented by grip six
the one you want and something um in a
kremling
showed to me um you know was like the
left to right
scanning of the board to double check
protected pieces
which in this game all of the games was
very helpful to me
and what i think i learned here is i
need to be doing that
earlier because i thought we're in the
opening blah blah blah
not like not like the opening is full
autopilot
but i definitely don't think to use that
until i'm in like not like a pickle
but like what what move should i make
next i don't know okay let me start by
scanning things and i think like
it's just a good it's like doing your
dishes you know
i just need to do the dishes
i'm glad that she told you about this
i'm gonna learn i think i'm gonna apply
that too from from anna because i also
say about the unprotected pieces but i
think it's it's a good idea that
if you have this so so much of a method
that it's like a scan from left to right
yeah that's new to me too so i'm
learning because the
the unprotected piece is extremely
important the king and unprotected
pieces
and when we when we did our puzzle
training at the very start and just in
general to spot
motives and ideas i i think you remember
that i told you about the
the king the unprotected pieces and the
unfortunately placed pieces those three
categories but yeah i like that from now
on you're gonna scan the board
from the opening on because you are
right it can be
as early as move four five six that
something is hanging
so it's good if you if you pay more
attention to unprotected pieces i agree
queen to c2 would have been a good idea
even
even like this again mistakes will
happen but it's good that you then
adjust to the new situation new
situation being oh
yeah we lost the pawn but the rook is
hanging
yeah so you move the knight away because
that's the only way to guard it
even if it loses a second pawn the rook
is
priority so you did the right thing by
moving the knight
queen takes c3 and bishop b5 check you
realize that now your bishop is hanging
so you moved it to b5 i think that's a
good reaction
because it wasn't so easy to guard it
what would happen if you
guard this bishop with the queen and i'm
not going to move it
i just want you to visualize it what's
wrong with that move
rook's hanging the rock is hanging yeah
our queen is too busy our queen cannot
handle
everything a same would be about queen
c2 and these are very easy blunders
this would be actually very easy to
blunder because
when something is guarded as of now then
you feel like it's not in danger and you
could easily move your queen away to
guard something that's
now in danger so you end up losing more
than what you have protected
i'm glad that you have spotted it
instantly so we ain't blundering
we and blundering that rook bishop b5 is
one of the best reactions for that
reason
even our knight with this pin so you
didn't have much of a choice bishop b5
to get out of this a very dangerous
situation for the bishop
bishop to d7 here you had the choice to
take
but in